guess I'd like to uh call the house uh
Judiciary Committee to order for an
executive session and I apologize to
people in the public for being a bit
late but we just had a few things we
needed to uh discuss and I'd like to uh
recognize uh representative Wallace to
lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
foreign
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
right
um
so
the uh
the first bill that I would like to take
up
um is HB
379 which we began to address
at our last executive session
um uh representative uh Reed and and
representative kutab and I think
representative Alexander and maybe
others uh representative Manos I think
um
worked on an amendment and uh
so uh so that is
um
amendments 347 is that correct
so um the chair uh recognizes
representative kutab for a motion
I make a motion to otpa with Amendment
347.
oh second Mr chair all right so uh move
by representative kutab second via
representative Alexander uh
representative would you like to speak
to your uh
the amendment here is just requiring
that
in the tenants notice to terminate which
is a standard form that's provided by
the state
that the eviction notice must clearly
state that the tenant may be eligible
for assistance from the New Hampshire
legal aid for legal counsel and it will
give information on how to obtain such
assistance it does not guarantee the
right to assistance just gives them the
information that they it may be
available to them
right
um any other discussion on
um Amendment uh 347 to HB 379.
I'm seeing none uh I think this is
something we can do by a Voice vote uh
on the amendment and then we'll have a
roll call on the on the uh Bill itself
um
so all those in favor of amendments 347
to HB 379 please say yay yay any opposed
all right no one uh no one opposed
motion carries unanimously now we're on
to the main bill
um so it would be uh HB 379 as amended
um
anyone want to have any further
discussion on that
seeing none I asked the clerk to please
call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrick yes rep
Grayson yes
clerk votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes
rep page
Brett Macbeth yes rep Divine yes rep
Lanza yes rep Manos yes repturer yes
chairman Lynn yes
20 years zero knees
379 uh otpa
um all right uh next I would like to
turn to uh House Bill uh 112 and the
chair recognizes uh representative Tripp
for a motion
imoviex in expedient to legislate is
there a second
I second that
trip would you like to speak to the
motion
thank you
uh
I believe there's three issues with this
bill
the the first is uh
that uh notices required
before
sale or transfer the property
uh
with 60 days notice that seems excessive
to me
uh
the
another term of the bill is that the
tenants have to be provided an
opportunity to meet the terms
of that are already agreed upon by the
uh the other buyer
um
and uh should should they be an issue
with their uh
obtaining financing or something that
would prohibit this they're being able
to purchase it the the period would be
extended beyond the 60 days
probably the biggest problem with this
bill is that that doesn't make any
accommodation for uh any tenants that
are not interested in participating in
the purchase uh this is going to make
the tenants being able to purchase the
property very difficult because there
may be
perhaps you know ten percent of the
existing tenants that are not interested
in uh buying the property which is going
to make it very difficult for the
remaining tenants to uh
uh
uh obtain financing and uh any other
thing that's a required to enable them
to purchase the property thank you
anyone else wishing to speak on 112.
yes representative Manos thank you Mr
chair there is an amendment that has
been circulated which I think would
address uh representative trips
um concerns regarding this bill and I
would ask the committee to consider the
amendment that's before us
um it
um
excuse me it reduces to 60 days notice
the notice to each tenant
and it simply provides them with the
information and
um notice is considered delivered to a
tenant by signature of receipt notation
of refusal or a certified letter and so
there that avoids the issues
um regarding what the tenants might do
upon receiving notice and whether they
would collectively seek to buy the
property or not
so I would request that we consider the
amendment thank you all right um well I
I mean I I definitely I appreciate you
raising that issue and if we if we were
to get to
um to to uh
the amendment is not on the floor now
because we're debating the issue of of
Ito but I mean I I I appreciate your
people people can certainly take into
account in deciding what to how to vote
what you've said I guess my my own
concern
um is I don't although
I guess I would I would agree that the
proposed amendment
makes the bill somewhat less
objectionable to me it the bill is even
with the amendment remains significantly
objectionable
um and I so I would I personally would
intend to continue to vote itl it just
seems to me
that this and there we're going to have
a number of other bills that are coming
along to be that we're going to be
executing
um that do sort of the same thing is
that there's you know to make it more
difficult for landlords to own and
manage and dispose of and do all kinds
of things with property in the theory
that somehow that's gonna make uh make
things better in the housing market to
me it's going to make things just worse
um to me the more you the more sort of
conditions and other kind of
restrictions you try to place on on
landlords
um the the result of that is simply
going to be that you're going to
discourage people from being landlords
which will mean less affordable housing
and and or and or the rent rents are
going to increase so although I do agree
that the amendment improves the bill a
little bit to me I would still vote itl
anyone else representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair um I would like to
just concur with your statement I think
the um big objection I have with this is
although this is restricted property so
four units or more I think that we run
into issues
um when cash offers are made and you
know somebody may have the cash for a
unit that's four units or more and in
that case you can have closings that are
you know three four weeks or even less
than even less than 30 days so
um this just really puts a restriction
on the the free market the housing
market it puts a restriction on the
supply which is what we're looking at is
we're looking at a supply side issue
with this housing crisis
um so this this regulation just really
hurts
um hurts the the transfer property
between people so I would agree with you
Mr chair yes representative Smith
thank you very much Mr chair um I want
to suggest that we should not be
conflating two issues one is the problem
that's occurring across the country and
certainly in New Hampshire about the
shortage of
um of housing affordable or not
um when we have the vacancy wraith that
that we see that's one issue but it's
that's something that I'm pleased that
my colleague
um
uh from where is going to be looking
into with a very specialized focused
committee looking at the housing
situation
separate from that is the rights of
landlords and tenants to be involved in
a process that is fair to everyone and
this was an attempt to recognize the
right of course of of a lender to be
able to sell property but also recognize
that at the same time it does have a
direct effect on the housing
opportunities for tenants so it's very
separate from the issue of availability
of housing generally I'm sympathetic to
what you say but I do think it attempts
to solve a problem without regard
to housing availability thank you anyone
else have anything they wish to say yes
representative Perez
my concern about putting
restrictions on landlords is
they're gonna say the heck with this and
they're going to flip them to be condos
and that happened in a huge area behind
where I live and if we continue to
put
weights on landlords
they may just throw their hands up and
say well I'm just going to sell all my
units as condos and then I don't have to
worry about it and that's only going to
hurt
the tenants because you'll have no
regulation basically over
what you can do to them so that's just a
concern all right representative Oregon
um
yes we've heard um we had lots of
hearings on this and other bills and two
things we heard over and over again is
one is and it's it's true the vacancy
rate is near zero it's a fraction of one
percent that rents are much higher than
what people can afford
and yet
we hear from the landlords that they're
they're suffering they're barely hanging
on they're on the verge of Bank well I
guess we've never heard the word
bankruptcy so
it makes me wonder
who's buying these properties a lot of
them are probably uh probably Bottom
Feeders because uh
you know if we actually do create more
housing Supply
um that'll drive the rents down that
they're already apparently losing money
giving so I
um so I think this bill uh I think so
I'm gonna vote knowing the itl these um
I think the amendment makes it makes it
better it's a difficult issue but I
think uh you know if the landlords
aren't making money now uh
that's the financial situation of the
new
of the new buyer is going to be even
even worse and he's probably uh going to
try to drive the expenses down to pay
for the cost of buying the property so I
think it's best to give the tenants
advance notice of what's going on um
and anyway and there is a condo
conversion obviously the tenants have to
have a lot of ample notice of that
because uh they're probably hoping to
sell the condos to the tenants and so
forth and there's very detailed rules on
that which are probably much more I'm
not an expert on it but I understand
they're way more restrictive than this
little thing we're passing here so I
would uh
I would just say given the nature of the
given the nature of the market and just
the leak short-term prospects I think we
should give this we should pass
something to give the tenants a little
bit more protection what's already like
a very difficult situation for all
parties involved thanks
anyone else uh wish to speak Mr chair
yes yes
thank you Mr chair just following up on
the um previous conversation about condo
conversion uh of a property
for me that could be an Avenue for a
tenant to buy a unit individually so you
know it's not all black it's not all
white
um but that is an opportunity if the
tenant can afford to put down in a down
payment
thank you
anyone else have anything they wish to
say on uh on this bill
all right I think we're ready for a roll
call vote on the motion of uh itl so I'd
ask the clerk to please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton YES Prep trip YES Prep
Grayson yes Clark kutab votes yes rep
Perez
rep Smith no
reporter again no rep D Lorenzo no rep
Eaton
rep page no Brett Macbeth no rep divine
no rap Lanza no rep Manos no
ripped her no chairman Lynn yes
motion fails and a tie Ten to Ten
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
I
excuse me I would now
um move my Amendment or excuse me it's
not my Amendment but I would move the
amendment to HP 112.
um
which is before us what's the amendment
numbers it's 2023-0252h
so to clarify the Motions ought to pass
with Amendment
thank you yes right okay I'm sorry what
could I just have one more time the
number of the amendment police
representative
2023-0252 h
all right great all right is there a
second to that motion
my seconded by representative tur uh
representative Manos would you like to
speak to the motion
um I think it improves the bill
I
misspoke when I said that it
um
changes the 60-day notice it doesn't it
maintains the 60-day notice but this
amendment would
um
strengthen the bill by making it simply
notice to the tenants
without regard to what action they might
take upon receiving that notice
um and
um it does maintain
it does maintain 60 days notice to the
tenant
um
and I think that that's reasonable I
take representative Alexander's point
that a cash offer could result in a
closing short of 60 days but I think
that this is reasonable in the
circumstances and I would move that the
OTA
to pass with the amendment thank you
anyone else wish to speak on this Mr
chair yes thank you Mr chair I think the
60-day notice sounds reasonable
um and so that's why I'm going to vote
otpa
okay anyone else wish to speak I guess I
would just say I that as I think we've
sort of covered before I I still believe
that this is not an appropriate
um way to go and so my I intend to vote
no on this anyone else uh we should
speak representative
I'll just say with the tight housing
market the the idea of notice becomes
that much more important because it'll
take that much longer for someone to
find an alternative so you know with
with no or less than that amount of
notice it can put people in a difficult
situation of housing instability
yes representative
I I do want to point out that just
because somebody's buying the property
doesn't mean that they can terminate the
leases they do still have to
keep the leases as were on the books
before so they wouldn't be evicting the
tenants or in the property
anyone else wish to speak
all right um although this is an oh I'm
sorry representative Perez
house cash offers on houses
Apartments whatever are turning over in
much less than 60 days now
um I live in a development and they're
turning over in as fast cash offers in
as fast as less than 30 days I think the
60 days is really puts a hardship on the
um another hardship on the landlord and
I just think that's hard
anyone else wish to speak
right given given the what the what has
happened already with regard to this
bill even though this is an amendment I
think I'm going to do this by a roll
call vote so could I ask representative
kutop to call the roll this will be only
on the amendment first and then we'll go
to the main bill so on Amendment
o252h uh
the motion is ought to pass that
Amendment uh so would you call the role
on that
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman
rep Stapleton no
prep trip no rep Grayson yes
clerk votes no
rep Perez
rep Smith yes
rep hoorigan yes
rep D Lorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes rep page yes
Brett Macbeth yes rep divine
rep lonza yes
rep Manos yes
Reptar yes
chairman Lynn no
Amendment passes eleven to eight eleven
to nine sorry eleven to nine oh so the
amendment passes um
we just voted on the amendment we just
voted on the amendment all right so now
we're on to uh the main bill
um uh HP 112 as amen as just amended
um anyone want to have further
discussion on the on the main Bill yes
representative horn
I would just say
in terms of these buyers you have to be
a pretty audacious buyer to buy into an
industry where apparently from what I've
heard you cannot you're losing they're
losing money even though they've sold 99
points they have 99.8 percent or
whatever their of their inventory rented
out and they're paying prices everybody
agrees are vastly higher than what
people can actually afford so if
if the current rental owners are
struggling even in that market you
basically want the person who's buying
these is either very brave or uh
maybe just very brave or there may be
something suspicious about them it's
like the tenants deserve some advanced
notice to find out who this person is
who's buying the property thanks
anyone else wish to speak on the main
bill
aren't seeing none then I would ask the
uh clerk to uh call the roll uh this the
motion before us is uh
otpa on House Bill 112.
I believe it's 117.
but no we haven't gotten to 117 yet this
is 112.
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no
rep Andrews no rep testerman no
rep Stapleton no reptrip
no
rep Grayson yes
clerk votes no
rep Perez
no
rep Smith yes
reporgan yes
rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton yes
rep page yes
Rhett Macbeth yes rep Divine yes rep
Lanza yes right Manos yes Rapture yes
chairman Lynn no
motion passes eleven to nine
Mr chairman yes yes uh can it uh I know
we didn't do it at the time can I can I
make a request for motion to put 379 on
the consent calendar oh no I'm glad you
did that yes okay yeah we have to finish
this first we haven't Oh I thought we
were done with this Mr chair just could
I write The Minority Report on this bill
uh sure who uh so who's going to write
the majority report on this bill
representative Manos would you
all right so um
yeah so hang on just one second so I
make some notes Here
and uh representative Alexander you will
write the minority
yes all right right
all right
all right all right um
yes I'm sorry now representative Turner
I said you wanted to put uh 279 on the
consent calendar correct
does that that sound yeah right 370.
anybody's 379 I'm sorry anybody have any
objection to that it sounds like makes a
lot of sense to me so all right
yes
um and we have a deadline at noon so
like yeah
okay so uh I'm gonna messenger now Mr Mr
chair yes the deadline would be noon
today that's probably not
uh reasonable
um I already wrote that we actually we
have a draft report that was kind of
number 379 379. oh yeah oh yes I'm sorry
I thought we were back to the southern
379 we had all agreed we all agreed to
it's going to be that's fine yeah yeah
no no I'm not I oppose any that kind of
deadline yeah
um so would you like would you like the
people from now on to get the report to
you when by tomorrow night or by Friday
um yeah I was gonna
um
I was going to say by Friday if we could
if I close a business on Friday that
these reports that that seems to me to
be reasonable thank you um all right so
then we'll turn to uh
House Bill 117
um
I know
there had been
um uh some the discussion about a
possible amendment to that
um as it was uh that that I'm not going
to go forward with that uh Amendment as
a result of some discussions had so
um
I would move uh HB 117
is there a second
I'm moving uh oh I'm
ought to pass 117 ought to pass a second
Ed by representative cutoff and I guess
I would like to speak to this
um
uh motion
um this bill has I've uh said that at
the hearing it is designed to overturn
what I think is really a very
unfortunate Supreme Court decision that
essentially says
that if you make a contract the lease
property for a year or or uh or some
other time because I suppose it could
even be five years but if you make a if
you make a contract to lease property
when the lease is uh and it's restricted
property when the lease is up you can't
and the you cannot evict the tenant
um the fact that the lease is up is not
enough to be able to evict the tenant
that seems to me to be
very very bad public policy it it
Bridges uh basic contract rights
and I think it also
has the effect of making again this is
another example of making housing less
available because
if you say to uh if you if the law that
a landlord has to comply with which is
what it is now is if you rent this
property to somebody
you're stuck with that person not just
for a year or whatever it may be you're
stuck with that person a landlord may
very well that may very well make a
landlord reluctant
to want to rent to somebody that the
landlord sort of considers marginal
because if the if the law was as it
should be I would submit that if you
make a lead if you make a contract for a
year or or two years or nine months or
whatever it might be
um when that when when the contract is
over you can end the contract then a
landlord might very well say okay
this person I've got some question about
whether this person will be a good
tenant whether the person will have the
ability uh to do sort of what what uh
tenants are supposed to do that kind of
thing but it's only a year so I'll take
the chance
um and at the end of the year if it
doesn't work out then you know I can
just end the lease
landlord can't do that now and so it
seems to me that that that that there
are at least some cases where that means
the landlord is going to say no if I'm
on the hook not just for a year but it's
that potentially forever I'm not I'm not
going to do this
um so that's why I um I think this this
amendment is a reasonable change to the
law
um and I hope you'll support it thank
you
representative Macbeth
thank you thank you I'm sorry
um I need to say that I don't consider
myself near the having the ability to
analyze cases like you do but I did and
I did pass out to everybody the case
that you're trying to overturn
um uh Miko versus
um I can't pronounce the last name
Cassidy
um I wanted to start I've I've given
everybody a copy one I want to start
with the one
um opinion that was a concurring opinion
by NATO that our chair mentioned when he
in his testimony
um and
um even
um Justice NATO says that
um he says the majority asserts that the
mere exploration of Elise is not good
cause I disagree I believe that the
statutory language and that's uh 540. it
does have other good cause is Broad
enough for the terminating of a tendency
at the expression of a lease so that's
the opinion that's the one opinion that
doesn't completely agree with the other
um for justices and if you go back to
the next page this will give you insight
to my mind I go backwards because I
think the biggest points are at the ends
of the cases
um but on page six and I've also um put
a thing around that
um it says the time for the landlord to
determine whether or not it's going to
rent to a tenant is established
um in the beginning
um when the landlord grants you know
offers the least it said the landlord is
of course not forced into a Perpetual
landlord-tenant relationship it may
terminate for good cause any time that
it wants by by the grounds laid out in
RSA 542.
so um I also want to say that on the
next page if we go back to five the
court lays out some unintended
consequences that I really would like
everybody to think about and instead of
an ought to pass maybe we could do a
routine and look at this a little bit
more but on on on page five paragraph
three it said if mere exploration of a
lease uh were constant to a good cause
then tenants would be evicted
arbitrarily from their homes through no
fault of their own and they would
undoubtedly at worst become homeless as
a result and then I'm going to go to the
last sentence and it explains why it's
important the landlord has the kind of
the balance of power in the beginning
they get to decide who they lease to and
then at the determination of the lease
it's they have to have good cause
because of these type of consequences if
a tenant is um for no cause of their own
evicted it says relationships with
friends and neighbors may be disrupted
children may be forced into new school
districts local services and support
system for elderly disabled tenants will
be lost which would all be contrary to
what the legislature intended when it
passed this law
the
RSA
542-2 that was in 1985.
um
um so
it it talks about and I'm not going to
go through the whole thing but on the
top of page four it outlines what this
other good cause is and several of the
justices mentioned that this other good
cause really is a catch-all for any
legitimate business or personal reason
that a landlord would have a landlord of
restricted property and so let's
remember that's not somebody that's
sharing property uh renting into their
home it's not anybody that has just less
than four units it's really one of you
know a commercial
landlord who I think are respectable and
not um I I differ with my colleague on
my left regarding how he would
characterize landlords because actually
we didn't see any landlords testify and
support of this I don't believe so
anyway I just want to say there's
there's a lot to this I'm not a great
linear thinker like our chair so a
little bit of sausage making doesn't
bother me and it's I think the Court's
really clear why the legislature why the
legislature did this
um and um and it outlines kind of
consequences so I hope I appreciate the
chairs
you know attempt to rectify this but I
really hope that some of you would join
me and let's at least retain this and
look at it it's just what the court says
is changing this to enacting this bill
would eviscerate the consumer
protections regarding what we have for
good cause of terminating leases so and
I see if you want to I did a highlight
that as well
um but anyway thank you
yes representative cuta
I just wanted to reflect for the record
that we did have two landlords that did
testify and support
um it was uh Nick Norman who's also the
chairman of the apartment association of
New Hampshire and David Klein who is a
landlord I don't have on the record any
tenants that were any sorry any
landlords that were opposed
other other uh thank you for that
so I guess just I
very briefly would you say this can you
imagine I mean the you know the one of
the things the majority said there was
somehow it would be arbitrary to
terminate at least when it's up that's
the argument it's it's arbitrary somehow
arbitrary to terminate the lease when
it's up
I I guess I would ask you to sort of
think about this if this is if that's
going to be if that's the law how about
in other contexts I mean if you have you
know you lease a car for three years can
uh can you say at the end of the three
years I have a right not to turn it in
um I mean what other what other
contracts would we say because maybe you
know you you need the transportation you
uh the the for the lessor thinks they
have a better use for it or whatever but
you need the transportation well we
can't we can't allow that to happen I
that's that's the thing I guess I just
have a problem with and I understand I
don't but I think the court is clear
it's not sending it's not applying this
to other areas it says this area
particularly when you're talking about
just restricted rental properties so
it's not all it's not doesn't apply to
commercial properties it doesn't apply
to a lot of rental properties it just
applies to these restricted rental
properties and I would say that we do
look at contracts with different like a
prenuptial agreement or a nanny Network
you mean the court looks and interprets
those contracts differently than it does
others because it wants to make sure
everybody got a fair Shake in this case
the legislature put in
5422 to protect clients because like it
says the client the the landlord needs
to make that decision about renting
initially they've got they've got the
balance of power up and then at the
termination of the lease it needs to be
for good cause it can't just be
arbitrary and it's because housing is so
special and at least I mean it also
making people housing is a huge
downshifting of costs because the
municipalities are going to have to take
care and pay for all the services for
those folks so I think particularly in
this rental environment it's just not
smart to do anything that's going to
destabilize that all right
representative Oregon
well
first of all I agree with my colleague
to my right uh that this bill shouldn't
be passed as is there was a statement
made by the clerk that no landlords came
in to testify uh
against the bill but actually the New
Hampshire Housing Association uh Miss
margolin from the nhha did come in and
they um they have a variety of groups in
there but they do include a number of uh
landlords because those are agencies I
guess in some cases maybe private
corporations with specialized in
affordable housing so that's a different
that's a somewhat different animal than
the general housing market but there are
some landlords who are in fact uh
opposed to passing this pill as is so
thanks representative Perez
follow up on representative
um catap said um when um Mr Norman and
Mr Klein testified one of the big things
that I wrote down that both of them said
is if they have a good client
they are good tenants they are not going
to arbitrarily get rid of them at the
end of the lease they will then renew
their lease because the cost to them to
have to replace that person
they have to take that into
consideration and
with all due respect yes they have get
to they screen the person coming in but
you really don't know someone until you
live with them so you could screen all
you want but you're not going to know
what that tenant is going to be like
until they're actually your tenant
anyone else
have anything to say on this bill
all right seeing none I would ask the
clerk to call the roll the motion is
ought to pass house bill 117.
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews no
rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes
rep trip yes
rep Grayson yes
Clark kutab votes yes Brett Perez yes
rep Smith
rep Horrigan no
rep Delorenzo no rep Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth no
rep Divine no replanza no red Manos no
Rapture no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails nine to eleven
I'd like to make the motion to retain
is there a second
I'll second it
seconded by representative Alexander
all right
all right is there a discussion on the
motion to retain anyone wish to be heard
on that
all right
um then let's ask the clerk to call the
roll on uh hb117 motion to retain
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews no
rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes
rep trip yes
rep Grayson yes
or qutab votes yes
rep Perez yes rep Smith
reporter again yes
Reptil Lorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes rep page yes
Brett Macbeth yes rep Divine yes
keplanza yes rep Manos no
Rapture yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 18 to 2.
okay
um
all right
uh representative McBeth do you want to
write okay
forget about there's no report good all
right
um
I think well it's
good oh my goodness
oh yeah
everything
all right all right yeah
so um
we're on um all right we're uh up to
um House Bill 235
um
establishing uh a commission to study
um expansion of a landlord Senate
mediation program and do I understand it
representative Alexander Andor De
Lorenzo have a motion on that is that
yeah
do you have a motion to uh amend is that
correct yes all right yes please I'd
like to make a motion to amend HB
otpa yep
yep all right and that's Amendment 148
is that correct
yes all right and I'll second the second
second by representative Alexander uh
representative Lorenzo would you like to
speak to your motion
well I think that
this is the good bill and I think that
it needs
to be explored by a study committee I
think it would be very helpful
and that's what the amendment is about
yes all right representative Alexander
do you want to say something yeah thank
you Mr chair
um I think this is a widely successful
program from what we heard in the public
hearing
um I would like to see more research
from Mr head and about more of the
details surrounding the landlord tenant
mediation program but the amendment I
think saves the taxpayers a lot of money
by turning it from a commission which
costs a lot of money to a study
committee in which a bunch of
legislators with a hundred dollars a
year will be able to study a widely
successful program so I'm looking
forward on sitting on this subcommittee
hopefully with representative De Lorenzo
this summer thank you
anyone else uh have anything to to say
on this
um all right so first on the amendment
um I think we can probably do that by
Voice vote
um so Amendment with uh the question on
the floor is amendment 148 H to House
Bill 235
um oh are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye aye any
opposed right so the motion carries
unanimously now to the main uh motion
House Bill 235
ought to pass as amended
um are you anyone want have any further
discussion or are we ready for the
question
oh yes representative Anderson sorry
thank you thank you Mr chair I am going
to end up voting against this bill
because this information in front of me
last year this bill formerly SB 2 216
was voted ought to pass on the senate
floor on a Voice vote in the Judiciary
Committee it was voted itl 11 to 9. on
the house floor the vote was itl on The
Voice vote so I am going to go along
okay all right
um anybody else uh wish to speak to the
main yes representative Alexander yeah
just briefly to distinguish there's this
is a different build than the one that
was voted out of this committee um itl
last term that was a commission
um this is just a legislative study
committee so a lot simpler and a lot
less expensive thank you so what I
should say some of you may be aware we
have a we have some Three Special
committees one of them is a committee to
deal with commissions because we have I
think correct me if I'm wrong
representative Alexander we have
something like 400 commissions some of
them haven't met it even my committee so
I don't know I'm a different special
committee some of them haven't met in
years and so the speaker I think uh uh
very wisely wants to see if we can kind
of
you know get a handle on this but
representative Alexander and
representative De Lorenzo very wisely
through this amendment have changed this
so this will be not a commission but a
committee will be composed only of
legislators it will be able to do its
its work and hopefully have a report To
Us by the Fall I would I think so I
think it's a much different situation
and that's why um
I think it makes sense to do what what
they've proposed at any rate um are we
ready for uh roll call vote on this all
right see no objection um then I'd ask
uh Mr representative Wallace if you
could call the role on House Bill 235 uh
otpa
Vice chair Wallace votes yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Andrus no
representative Testament yes
representative Stapleton yes
representative Tripp yes representative
greeson yes
representative koutab
representative Perez yes
representative Smith yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative De Lorenzo yes
representative Eaton yes representative
page yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative Devine yes representative
Lanza yes representative Manos
yes
representative Terror yes chairman Lin
votes 18 1 and 1.
yes representative
object I would think this could go uh
consent okay
um
sent and um
second
and uh
uh representative Delorenzo or
representative Alex who will write the
report uh representative De Lorenzo yes
I would like to Great certainly thank
you and that's due on Friday correct due
on Friday yes please thank you
porch hang on one second
all right all right um then let's turn
to uh
House Bill 261 authorizing residential
tenants to terminate their lease in
instances of domestic violence or
following a disabling incident or
accident uh the chair recognizes
representative Perez for a motion
thank you I would like to move make a
motion to itl this Bill thank you is
there a second I second the motion all
right the motion has been moved and
seconded uh representative Perez would
you like to speak to your motion yes um
the concern was a lot of vagueness in
this um
um
as far as disability
um how do we find is it a short-term
disability is it a long-term disability
the term no longer enjoyable seemed
extremely vague
um it's there are other things as far as
the um
as far as determinating with domestic
violence
are we terminating because the the
person is the defective violence person
or the person is being
violenced against it just was way too
vague in the way that it was
all right
anybody else wish to be heard on
okay
I'm not sure I think uh Virginia
oh yes representative divine
yeah I'd like I'd like to make uh
there's an amendment circulating that
that would make the bill exclusive to
domestic violence I'd like to introduce
that
um yeah you can't do it okay
so I can only talk about it it basically
just takes out
um it keeps everything the same except
for it removes the disabling accident
part
um lines
15 through 25 just to make a little bit
simpler
and I think there seemed to be a lot
more sympathy or whatever towards
victims of domestic violence
um and there's not really it enables
them to get out of a difficult situation
and this bill would allow for that where
right now there's nothing that is
available to them to actually get out of
a lease if they have to if their life is
threatened
yes representative Perez I apologize I'm
new at this one of the things I forgot
to bring up with this bill as well is
so if we have this for both disability
and domestic violence
why is that any different than me
terminating my lease because I have an
issue I lost my job
it can open the can of worms as I say or
Pandora's Box to
adding additional things on to this type
of legislation
so yes representative tur yeah just uh
sort of in response to that and also
sort of in support of the amendment
potential Amendment
um
the I think the the reason for taking
the the second part out the disability
is these are very different situations
that are sort of rolled into the same
piece of legislation sort of
inappropriately so I think it's much
cleaner to focus on domestic violence in
the state
already goes to Great Lengths to protect
the location whereabouts of victims of
domestic violence and in other
situations and the presence of uh their
known whereabouts is an immediate
hardship to the person who's suffering
so I think I think passing this would
provide a necessary relief for that
group without sort of muddying the
waters
yes representative Macbeth thank you so
uh just to speak to the amendment and
actually my colleagues comments
regarding domestic violence I think the
thing that carved out for domestic
violence why it's significant not only
do sometimes victims need to keep their
residents secret but in many instances
because the domestic violence statute
requires you be it'd be an intimate
partner it's somebody that you are
living with so your your lease needs to
be
terminated both by you and you know so
it would be the victim and the defendant
because they can no longer afford to
live there probably
um so I think that DV is a special it
has a special difference there may be
other you know groups as well but I
think it really would be I hope that
people will listen and and consider the
amendment by um our colleague
anyone else wish to be yes
representative greeson
thank you Mr chair
addressing the issue of of uh domestic
violence uh a a landlord does not want
some creep coming around the property
and causing Havoc for any of his tenants
or her tenants
and so if there is a restraining order
in place
there's an issue of
if that if the tenant that is being
harassed in whatever way needs to be
able to get out of the of the uh of the
of the lease because the situation is
escalating or could potentially escalate
you can avoid
the midnight move outs that the
landlords have testified that becomes
very problematic because at some point
in time the victim of this abuse is
going to say I've just got to get out of
here and so they just leave in the
middle of the night you also can
eliminate the um by being able to to
move out and
the Privacy uh the Privacy rights being
protected
um you prevent the potential abuser from
being able to find out where that person
has moved the victim has moved on to so
I think you can actually prevent a lot
of issues by by allowing the the
termination of a lease because of this
situation
avoiding those midnight move outs and
still permitting it to take place I
think an amendment I don't like the I
think trying to cover both the uh the
bill as it is originally written I think
is problematic and I would I would itl
the original bill but to amend it to
just deal with the domestic violence and
allow for the termination in these
instances I think is is prudent
anyone else wish to be heard
so I guess I my take on this is I I I'm
I'm gonna vote in favor of itl because
again this is another
this is another example so now we've
made if we pass this now we've sort of
told the landlords you have another
thing to be worried about you have to
worry you have to run the risk that if
there's a domestic violence thing you
will you potentially will have to
terminate the lease give back the
security deposit I guess in those
situations because at least there will
be a proper termination of the lease and
so this is another this is another sort
of you know uh Cloud on the horizon so
what are landlords going to do well some
of them presumably are going to get out
of the business of being landlords
but more likely what they're going to do
is say well I I may have this risk so
what will I do well I'll raise the rent
that's what I'll do that will cover to
sort of cover for the potential increase
in in the risk I don't think that that's
what we want to do particularly at this
time so I I intend to vote itl on uh
261.
um anyone else wish to be anyone else
wish to be heard all right um are we
ready for the question then I would ask
the clerk to call the roll and the
motion is itl on House Bill 261.
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson
yes
clear crew tab votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
reporter again no
rep dilorenzo no rep Eaton uh yeah
repetan
rep page no Brett Macbeth no rep Divine
no rap Lanza no rep Manos no Rapture no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails in a tie 10 to 10.
can we offer another motion yes
so
um
I I like to motion to
um proceed with this amendment to
uh the number is
zero three five one h
uh pretty much everybody should have it
um
yes so what could you give me the number
one more time please
zero three five one h
H okay
you know I'm going to call a uh I'm
going to call p61.
a few minutes to uh
yeah I think I can still call emotion I
think I can still call a recess so I'm
going to call a recess for
a couple of minutes right
Mr chair Mr chair
we can't do that during the day
thank you
before we get back to taking any votes
um I would ask that
um there are actually two different
amendments for this bill
and
the the one that we're presently
discussing only addresses the domestic
violence part of it of the original bill
okay the other Amendment deals with both
portions of the original Bill the
problem is
is I like the wording of the not yet
mentioned uh
Amendment
of the domestic violence piece of it but
I don't want I don't like the the
disability portion of that Amendment so
I would ask if like if my colleagues
would
actually
vote no
on at the current vote to vote it down
so that we can move to retain this so we
can mesh the Amendments uh and have one
workable Amendment because otherwise I
have to vote down both amendments and I
think that that misses the issue
so I think I'm I
I guess
um
well I mean I I guess it's sort of up to
the people that support the support the
amendment whether they want to uh I mean
I guess it's I guess I would say In
fairness to everyone I want everyone to
at least speaking for myself and I don't
know about my my colleagues but speaking
for myself
um
I want to make sure that everybody
understands that even that I would
oppose whichever version of the
amendment is I would still oppose it so
don't I mean I don't want anybody to
think if if you
I don't want anybody to vote no
on the assumption that there might be
some change in heart on the part of
others of us other than representative
griesen so if you you know if you if you
vote no
um
it's a no vote that's
I guess that's I guess that's the best
way I can put it
yes certainly amendment that we're
talking about now
is 351 H and that's the amendment that
removes the last section
of the bill
um
uh dealing with generally with
disability is that correct
and then the the amendment that
representative Grayson is talking about
is 420
and that's the one that makes
a number of changes in each section is
that correct
420 is the other man right okay I just
wanted to know who was on first
and can I clarify for a second and what
Greece what representative Grissom was
suggesting is to combine
um the domestic violence
added to
420 and add that to 351.
is that correct
do I understand that is that
okay representative Turner
uh yeah I I mean I I in terms of the
retain question
um you know I still sort of feel like
these are separate and would best be
dealt with separately so I still like
the idea of the the narrower domestic
violence only version but I'm wondering
if if uh representative Grayson could
say a bit more about what is problematic
in that version of the amendment
foreign
the other Amendment uh 420420
addresses uh the landlord May charge the
tenant and early termination fee not to
exceed 50 of the monthly rental amount
this fee shall be prorated to be 50 of
the monthly rental amount if the initial
tenant rental agreement began less than
six months prior to termination and 25
percent of the rental amount if the
tenant lived in the property six months
or more so it allows that the landlord
to recover uh some of those fees that
would be experienced in an early
termination that were concerns from some
on this on this panel uh but otherwise
it pretty much leaves everything else
the same we could do a side-by-side uh
on it
um
but I like the idea of the landlord
being protected as well and and just
that recouping of of the cost of of a
early termination uh but while still
protecting uh the the victims of
domestic violence appreciate the
clarification thanks
so representative Mouse
thank you Mr chair
um
on other occasions where we have uh been
close but language needed to be tweaked
we basically held consideration over
until we could tweak it and then present
it and I'm wondering whether this would
be another appropriate case to do that
and I would be more than happy to work
with um
representative Grayson and
representative Devine to do that
yeah
so anybody have any any other uh
anything anybody anything that any
anybody else wants to say on this
um I think that probably does make sense
to just we'll just
um hold off we won't you know we won't
finish the exacting on this until uh
next time or whatever and then uh you uh
you can representative Grayson you can
work with uh
um representative Divine or
representative tour or whatever or
whoever really on trying to come up with
language that
um that makes sense is that uh anybody
have any problem if we do that uh what
is the uh reporting deadline on this
this is not an early bill so the it um I
believe yeah let me hang on I'm pretty
sure I think we can go to March yeah
yeah yeah it's not this is not an early
bill so March 19th so we have to we have
time so I would probably so probably
what I would do is put this on the first
the exact you know the our next exact
session which will be after
you know where where we will do the
exact session on many of the abortion
bills and that kind of thing we'll
probably do do this one at that time too
okay right that that makes sense that
makes sense
and we know who's going to get that
Amendment together
Divine reason and divine and Manos okay
um sure and of course representative
Reed who's not on the committee but is
very impressed right right
um all right
um
all right
okay
um
so yeah launch uh
all right so uh
this is
quarter one
um I suspect that some people are
getting hungry should we uh take a
recess anybody have an objection if we
take a recess for about uh 45 minutes or
so how about back at one third back at 1
30. that makes sense all right we are in
recess
not bad
sorry
I guess um
before we move on to House Bill 283
um it's my this it's my understanding
from uh we just had this discussion
yesterday at the chairs meeting in
committee
any member can file a motion to
reconsider uh whether you're on the
winning side or the losing side
So based upon my discussion with
representative Andrus it's my
understanding that she may have had I'll
obviously ask her to speak to it but
it's my understanding that she has may
have had a misunderstanding as to the
purpose of House Bill 117
and so on the basis of that I'm going to
ask for a mo I'm going to move to
reconsider that
I want to emphasize this I hope that the
body will agree to reconsider it I
completely understand and would expect
that
if we reconsider and then we get to the
motion on the merits I suspect it will
very likely be a 10 to 10 vote and I
completely understand that so I just
want to emphasize I I I'm I'm asking for
reconsideration only so that we may go
from retain which it is now to a 10 to
10 vote of no recommendation and as I
said because I believe representative
Andrews may have misunderstood
the what the bill
um accomplished so representative Mr
chair I'd be happy to move
reconsideration as a courtesy to my
cup well I very much appreciate I very
much appreciate that
um so I guess representative Andrus did
you uh did you
yeah the only thing I wanted to say I
want to apologize I misunderstood what
some of the bill what it was going to
happen and so uh now I understand that
fully and I apologize that we're going
to vote have to vote again thank you
I uh so I would move and yes I do have a
second representative Smith is second so
so uh
yes of course
are we just taking one reconsideration
vote on both motions or do you have to
take separate votes on the retained
motion and then backtrack and and uh
reconsider the other so so I think um so
I guess the the motion for
reconsideration would be on the motion
to retain if that if that passes
um then we've reconsidered the motion to
then the motion to retain is up for
um a vote I suppose we then have to vote
on that if that um
if that fails then we would be uh back
on to the motion uh I believe of OTP is
that is that your understanding about
representative Smith well whatever if
retain fails right then we would the
bill would be open to another month
another month right right sure I'm sure
that was all right so the motion uh to
reconsider has been made and seconded
and could I ask uh the uh I guess we
need I think we need a roll call on this
so could I ask the clerk to this is a
motion for reconsideration
uh on House Bill
117. so could I ask the clerk to call
the roll in that please
chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep Grayson
yes
Clare could have votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith YES Prep for again yes rep
Delorenzo yes rep Eaton rep page
Rhett Macbeth
no
rep Divine yes
rep Lanza yes
rep Manos
yes
repturer
chairman Lynn yes
and I guess I want to say I want to
thank my colleagues on both sides of the
aisle for that for for your vote on this
I completely understand that on the
merits you have you may have a different
view from some of us but I I very much
appreciate the courtesy of your vote on
this
the total vote on the motion to
reconsider was 19 to 1.
so now
um
the motion the the motion to retain is
what's on the floor
um
well no no I'm sorry we that the motion
to retain we've we've reconsidered that
and and now is it oh I think it's
retained on the floor now don't you have
to fame we have so do we want to I think
you have
okay all right sorry so
um the the motion to retain is what's on
the floor and I guess I would
um I would uh urge that that motion uh
be be rejected so that we can have a
another motion which
just to sort of play this out my if that
motion if we vacate the routine then I
would move
ought to pass I suspect that that will
fail out of 10 to 10. I want to do one
at a one at a time
okay all right one is the S line that's
fine all right so on the on the motion
uh to on the reconsideration of the
motion to retain
um I think we're ready for a roll call
vote and I I would urge people to vote
uh not to retain the bill
my position would be we should vote no
on retaining it so that that so they're
correct retain will fail and then we
will have it will be open to further
motion no the only comment I want to
make on that Mr chairman is unless I'm
wrong you have only one vote
I do I have only one vote
all right
okay so for HB 117 on the motion to
retain Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no
rep Andrews no rep testerman
rep Stapleton no reptrip no rep Grayson
no
clerkutab votes no rep Perez
rep Smith
reporigan yes
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes
rep page yes
Brett Macbeth yes
rep Divine YES Prep Lanza yeah yes rep
Manos yes Rapture yes
chairman Lynn no
tie 10 to 10.
so
and am I understanding
I I I guess I'm asking you to
know has failed and so now we're
open to another
thank you no I I appreciate that I
thought that was right but uh but but
I'm I appreciate your guidance on this
so I would now back we're sort of back
and I would make a motion of ought to
pass on 117 and I I won't in the
interest of saving time I won't I would
have made I would say the same things I
said before of why I think it ought to
pass uh and that's all I have to say
foreign
so any anybody uh wish to speak further
all right I think we're then ready for a
roll call vote on 117 ought to pass
um
I think the semantics are wrong the
motion was to reconsider pertained that
motion failed so retaining withstand
Center
right so that means the motion that
means retain fails
to return
you may be you may be right
um
all right sorry folks we're going to
take a couple of minutes we're going to
take a brief reset while I I like it
guys
the rep for people who are in the
audience I just called to get guidance
from the clerk on this because I I
thought representative Eaton had a very
valid point but what the what the clerk
explains to me uh we never had these
parliamentary procedures Supreme Court I
have to say
right right next so what the clerk
explained to me is
we voted to reconsider the motion to
retain and we said we wanted to do that
we we approved that motion
that so that means that the what is
before the committee what is before the
committee then is should we retain the
bill and we had a tie vote on that which
means that that motion to retain fails
so now we are up for a vote on on other
motions and I've made the motion of
ought to pass so that's the that's the
issue before us now I believe as
representative Smith
was was saying is if we vote on this
motion of ought to pass if it fails and
there's another motion we would vote on
that if that fails then I think motion
to retain would still would then be in
order again
there has to be an intervening motion
there is an intervening motion because
we're now voting ought to pass right and
who knows it might pass who can tell
right all right so no so anyway thank
you all for your your guidance on this I
appreciate it so the the motion on the
floor is ought to pass on House Bill 117
and I would ask the clerk to please call
the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson
yes
clerkutab votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
reporter again no
rep Delorenzo no
rep eaten
rep page no
rap Macbeth no rep Divine no replanza no
rep Manos no ripped her no
chairman Lynn yes
Ty 10 to 10.
so that motion fails is there another
motion
Ito
um
but
representative oh I'm sorry no I'm sorry
yes of course I just wanted to ask a
question what will the result be if the
motion to retain
fails
that goes without recommendation right
well no you know what there could be I
mean no then there I think they're
correct me if I'm wrong I think there
could then be another motion of itl and
we would vote on that and if that and if
that also fails then it would go without
recommendation
uh
thank you for the clarification
so um we have a motion uh to retain
that was seconded
emotions oh I'm sorry we have a second
on the motion to retain
not seeing a set oh okay the seconded by
representative divine uh Professor
McBeth do you wish to say I mean are you
happy to say anything I think I said
okay all right so
um motion's been made and seconded
um uh to retain
um House Bill 117 and are we ready uh
for the vote Yes we are so I'd ask the
clerk to please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no
rep Andrews no
rep testerman no rep Stapleton no rap
trip no rep Grayson no
Claire kutab votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
repor again yes
rep dilorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes rep page
rep McBeth yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza
yes rep Manos yes Reptar yes
chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
yes
representative share recognized
representative Smith
yeah
all right all right anyone wish to uh
speak further on this on the itl motion
and for those people who didn't think it
was fun to be in the legislature this is
an example of how much fun
[Laughter]
yeah I guess I just want to speak again
I'm sorry that um we are reconsidering
this bill but I just want to remind
everybody that this has been a policy
for over you know 30 years almost 40
years and or more since 1985 and it the
Supreme Court has been clear it this
voting for one one seven eviscerates the
consumer protections for tenants that
they can be arbitrarily
um
evicted without Just Cause And there's
no need to do this landlords have other
tools which the case clearly stated it
has for good cause which is for any
legitimate business or personal
um reason so I hope that people will
reconsider and not let this bill go
forward
I guess I just have to say respectfully
I just uh for the reasons I said before
I just disagree I mean you know as I
tried to point out at the urine it seems
to me that
this really sort of encourages you know
if you I mean as I said at the time is
this you know if this bill fails is this
like the end of the world landlords are
going to be in you know in a terrible
situation no but but
what it it seems to me what it what
having the law the way it is now
encourages
landlords to come up with with some
other reason in other words you know
instead of the like the lease is just
over and I don't particularly this is
not a particularly good tenant
um but I don't want to have to go
through the hassle of saying uh you know
you're a drug dealer try to prove that
in court or whatever so they so the
landlord raises the rent whereas maybe
they wouldn't raise the rent and they'd
be no to an amount that they know the
tenant can't pay and then the tenant is
evicted on that way do we does it really
make sense to to allow to that the
landlord has to kind of you know go
through those machinations
um maybe maybe you know to some extent
to some extent
you might say dishonestly because if
they really if they had what they the
power that they should have under the
law you made a contract for a year it's
over when a Year's up it's over we
wouldn't have that so that's why I think
it just just kind of is bad public
policy anyway that's that said my piece
the other thing this is if I know I
cannot get rid of somebody at the end
I'll just raise the rent
but whatever days you have to give them
that I'm raising the rent in
they'll be gone that way this makes it a
lot easier if they don't want to get rid
of them it just it makes sense
anyway so I guess are we ready are we
ready for the vote
all right I guess we are so this is on
the itl motion
um and I'd ask the clerk to call the
roll please
chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no
rep testerman no rep Stapleton no rap
trip
no prep Grayson nope
no
rep Perez no
rep Smith
rep hoorigan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yes
yes rep page yes
Brett Macbeth
yes
rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos
yes reptierer yes
chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10. all right so all
right well yeah yes could I ask for us
to reconsider the vote to reconsider uh
hb117
aye
yeah can we have more than one motion to
reconsider I um
I I'm asking to reconsider whether or
not the committee reconsiders that the
initial vote
I I'm not sure if you can or not but I'm
I'm not in you know you you you all gave
us the courtesy of of voting to
reconsider off so I'm not going to say
no we can't do that so there's a motion
to reconsider is there a second
Mr chair I don't think you can
reconsider a vote I don't think we can
reconsider a reconsideration
I'm not sure but
listening to work representative
Alexander who is sometimes right right
and I don't
I mean you could go and Paul attend but
I I don't think so you know what can I
think we have a future
uh
I mean we could
we could go back to retain and
the bill could be protected that way
um if you would like that
um or we could agree to send it to the
full without recommendation
I personally have had problems with that
because overwhelmingly our votes have
not
it had not
succeeded in supporting
OTP and that would be the first motion
if it goes to the floor without a
recommendation so we would we would have
to either support that on the floor or
argue against it and
those of us who believe that the
important work of the legislature is
done in committee
I know I would personally
not be comfortable wanting to
um argue against
what would be the the first vote which
would be ought to pass but the committee
hasn't been able to support octopus and
that's why I think
in the best interests of those who
support the bill and those who oppose
the bill I would again suggest that we
consider
retain where we that gives us the
opportunity
to see if we could come to some
agreement
um maybe we can't
but with time we might be able to come
to some agreement and
believing that it's always best to get
to Yes
um
I would again suggest that we
consider
the possibility of detaining the bill
and giving us time to see if we can find
out where we
if there is any way to get gifts maybe
the answer will be no Mr chair but I
think it's worth trying
yes representative cutoff
if representative Smith thinks that
there may be a way to possibly
compromise on this would it be possible
that we could recess this one until
another future hearing rather than
retain it because it's not an early bill
it's not due until the is it 3 16
um so that we could
try and reach some sort of a compromise
by the end of this month I think when
the next session was the 24th or 25th we
were aiming for for then might that be
something to consider
um rep Smith if you if if you're
thinking that we may be able to
do you think we could reach a compromise
in a timely way
chair I think that we've indicated up
until now that we're really evenly
divided we have a number of other
important bills to get through today
next week on Tuesday we have a session
on Wednesday and Thursday we have two
very difficult days of hearings and the
following week
um
we have at least two session days well
we have at least one and probably two
session days I think we have a lot on
our plate and and it might be time to
take a little break from this
and let us get back to it a few months
from now what if we can be more relaxed
so my suggestion is that we I don't
think we can I would not think we can
come up with an
a successful solution in the next couple
of weeks all right yes representative
Horgan
um
of course I'm bending the rules a little
bit by speculate about what some other
body might do but the Full House
does have a track record of tabling uh
many bills most of which are itl bills
that they were might not be itl but um
that's certainly a distinct possibility
if this ends up on the floor with an itl
that like
someone I'm not going to speculate who
will jump in with a tapling motion
before the IDL can be voted on in which
case the bill dies on the table and then
can be reintroduced identical bill or a
similar bill can be reproduced during
the pre-2024 filing period so I
appreciate it so you know what can I add
so we oh I'm sorry somebody else Mr
Speaker oh yes representative please
just just one quick comment in support
of this idea um I think there's two
things that I see with this that are
they're problematic one one of them is
sort of housing continuity which is kind
of the big piece and then the other one
is
um
the question of discrimination in the in
the re underlying reason for terminating
someone's lease because most of what
I've heard for the reasoning for for
this is bad tenant ill without really a
definition of what that is and sort of
an open-ended so I I do see maybe that
there is some some room in that regard
for for closing that up a bit so that
would be one reason in favor
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair
um
last week we sent a bill to the floor
without recommendation that all
10 Republicans voted against that will
go ought to pass I mean I understand
what representative Smith is saying but
that's just the unfortunate result of
having a 10 10 committee is there are
going to be some bills that go to the
floor without recommendation and the
first motion might not be the one that
we necessarily support as a committee
but that's just how house rules are so I
would just say that let's exhaust all
motions and then send this so far
without recommendation so you know what
I guess what I I
as I said I I very much appreciate the
fact that our colleagues who disagree
with us on the merits of this permitted
the motion for reconsideration so I I
don't know representative Beth weather
we can properly have this second motion
for reconsideration or not but I'm
willing to say let's I'm willing to you
know not press that point and say let's
have a let's let's do it but I guess
what I would say is before we before we
have that vote could I I mean would it
make sense to have just sort of an
informal show because if the vote if
that motion is is also if you're a
motion to reconsider is also going to
fail 10 to 10
I'm not sure what the what the purpose
is but I'm I'm willing
the motion
no she's she's moved to reconsider
the reconsideration
no it would be the motion to reconsider
the reconsideration that would fail so
that that's it yes
good delay with the talk to call about
possibilities
correct reconsiderations not
reconsideration is now reconsidered all
right right all right so I think no I
think the it sounds like what I'm
hearing from people on both sides of the
aisle so to speak is that that we can't
really reconsider the reconsideration
yes we we yes we could go back to retain
um
so
I guess I'm
I appreciate what you say representative
Smith I guess I'm kind of more of a mind
to have it go to the floor I understand
what you're saying and I but I would be
more inclined to do that but
you know I I certainly I'm not if if you
make a motion to to uh retain now and
it's seconded and then we'll you know
we'll have a vote on that and maybe I
you know people may agree with your
position I'm certainly not an
unreasonable position I just Mr I'm
looking at the time it's ten after two I
would assume that I am not the only one
who would like us to go through all the
bills today and not have to come back
tomorrow absolutely now I hope that
doesn't speak poorly of my commitment to
my legislative responsibilities
um but I I would consider the
possibility of taking a straw of up
given
you know we've thought back and forth
and back and forth we've tried to
respect the different views and I
believe that if we retain the bill we
might end up in a few months with the
way to get support for this bill and get
it through with some changes probably
minor
um if that is not a chance that people
want to take that's fine I understand
that so let's see if you would consider
it how many people would now consider
given the way we've been divided would
consider
retaining the bill to see if we could
put more positively address it and if
that fails in a straw bug then I would
say let's just stop then and let it go
to before with that recommendation
yes but yes representative I just want
to understand correctly because I am
newer so if this went to the floor with
no recommendation and it it didn't pass
at that point if if something new was
entered for 2024 that was different than
what's there now would that be allowed
because it's different so could could we
essentially just put it to the floor see
what happens if it doesn't work out then
we can try and work something out for
next time without having to keep just
re-voting on this now
that's I think it would I mean I I think
it would depend on how different it is
you know there could be there could be a
yeah it'd have to be substantive
or is going to be off the patch
and
um
there will be arguments in favor about
the past and there will be arguments
against artifacts and then a vote will
we take it and we don't know what the
vote will be if the vote is ought to
pass then it goes to the Senate if the
vote is
um if that vote fails then the next vote
would be RTL and if that passes it
wouldn't go to the Senate somewhere
along there anyone could argue
um for the build of a table and then the
bill could be brought off the table at
some point between now and the end of
the session
um
and that would be done by people who
have counted who's present and who is
not present because they'll take a guess
as to whether they're the people in
favor I guess as to whether they're
better off tabling or better off going
ahead with the vote and that can't be
decided in advance it has to be decided
when we see who shows up
um and so there are lots of you know
there's still lots of opportunities uh
uh I would hope that the committee would
want to keep control of the bill because
obviously
a lot of people care about it positively
and negatively and by retaining it we
keep control we don't give it to the
house to patrol
um but if you want to give it to the
house then what will happen is the it
goes to the floor with no recommendation
with the um
the first motion of ultipax
so I guess
um
I I appreciate the points that you make
representative Smith and I and
some of them I might
um agree with
um but I on balance I guess I I would
tend to say I would rather have it go to
the floor and just have the have the
votes on it and I understand that
um it would be
ought to pass so but but if you make a
motion to retain and it's seconded then
we will we will take a vote on that for
sure you don't want to try a straw dog
just to avoid well well so no no that's
a good point so let me just ask you if
assuming that the motion to retain was
made and seconded and I just asked for a
show of hands who would vote to support
that
one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten so it would be Ten
to Ten and that would and that would
fail so so thank you so I think we've
had a good discussion on this and uh and
I appreciate as I say I appreciate the
everyone's having this discussion all
right um
I will write that thank you all right so
all right so I'll write the majority on
this and uh representative Macbeth's
we'll write the uh Mr chair just to
clarify it's a statement in support of
ought to pass the majority report
because I'm sorry yes yeah right exactly
um
uh Macbeth okay
right right
e and i t l okay
all right
so I think
um we now turn to uh
House Bill uh
283 and
um I recognize representative Tripp for
a motion
I move in expedient to legislate is
there a second
president Stapleton
right uh representative Tripp would you
like to discuss your motion yes
um this bill deals with uh application
fees uh charged to a potential tenant
uh
in the in the process of vetting the uh
tenants
ability or the
the
tenants background
uh I have two problems with this bill
uh
first off it uh it calls out that there
can be no application fee in excess of
35 dollars
uh the issue I have here is that uh
should the initial uh vetting uh return
a a bad indication there'll be
additional fees due to uh uh
additional vetting carried out by the uh
the landlord
the second issue is that it uh says that
uh
fees for the rental application process
shall not exceed 250 dollars the the
issue here is uh
in times of inflation like this the uh
the vetting fees will undoubtedly
increase and uh anything over 250
dollars would be uh at the expense of
the landlord
you know these are the two reasons I
have to ask for an Ito
yes representative page thank you thank
you Mr chair um I'll be voting against
the motion itl I do have Amendment
that's gone around
um that I think addresses representative
trips concerns
um there it would um
not have a cap or any speak to any um
fee per se
um it would allow the landlord to charge
um charge whatever fee he or she would
deem necessary and then the only
difference would be that the um the
amendment would provide that the person
who actually takes the place is charged
charged the fee so I think that was
something that came up in hearing
um I think this is going back to what
we've heard we've had a threat of
uh comments on on landlord tenant issues
and um talking about I think ultimately
fairness to the parties involved I think
this is we this is an amendment that
addresses uh that issue of fairness we
we did hear testimony during
um hearing about
um how prohibitive
it can be for a prospective tenant to
Fork over 40 50 bucks for
a shot at a a 10 10 apartments that they
have maybe not won't get
um so so I think that's a lot of money
for anybody and certainly a lot of money
for folks who are trying to find a place
a place to live I'm skeptical
um that this would impact any sort of
Supply to these sentences Supply it
could be a supply question I'm skeptical
that would would uh impact that I mean
we've heard round and round around the
supply is effectively zero I'm not an
economist but I'm not sure it could get
much much worse so hopefully the
amendment addresses the questions that
representative Tripp had raised thank
you any other comments from anyone I've
I've sort of back to I intend to support
the itl and I'm sort of back to what we
said before the the you know the what
what this will what a landlord will tell
Will if this comes into effect what a
landlord will figure in the calculations
is that here's you know now I've been
Limited in this the rent goes up so
we'll have higher rents and I I don't
see how that's really in anybody's
interest anyway I've said my piece uh
other people yes representative Turner
yeah I just wanted to say and again I
know the amendment's not uh offered yet
but um if I'm looking at the right one
here then you know it's very much of a
rewrite of the original Bill and it it
seems like a really great bipartisan
compromise
um that takes into account all the
testimony that we got in terms of all
the various problems without placing any
hard caps on anything it avoids all the
churning and such that was that was
described in terms of all the various
fees that are collected and sometimes
collected potentially without even the
intent of renting if it's if it's that
type of market so I I would hope that we
would get to a point where we can hear
um a choice on that Amendment all right
anyone else wish to be heard
uh yes representative Perez you all have
heard that there is pricing Wars on
houses being built well there are
actually pricing Wars on rentals and
this would allow forbid a
um a landlord from taking you and I both
apply we both passed the background
check you did it first but I'm going to
offer him 75 more a month landlords
should have the option to do this that
takes that away
anyone else wish to be heard on 283. all
right so I then the motion before us is
on itl on House Bill 283 and I would ask
the clerk to please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes reptrip
yes rep Grayson yes
clerk who tab votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
reporter again no rep Delorenzo no rep
Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth no rep Divine no prep
Lanza no rep Manos no
repturer no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10.
they're another emotion yes could I
Mr chair yes I I would make a motion to
OTP with an amendment um numbered 422
that's been around
passed around
or 22. well that's is that the one
representing that I gave did I give you
that I don't want to say you have it
okay all right
two
representative page do you have extra
copies of that I just I don't see that
in front of me uh I believe
representative Reed had passed those
around earlier
um
I've no no I've seen it so I've seen it
but but other it sounds like a lot of
other people have not so
who else did
you think
anybody else need a cop yeah
I apologize I don't I thought that went
around
I'm happy to give you Mike I see it I
was looking for your name on the top I'm
sorry I don't see it so that's why I was
looking for another one okay it's 422.
uh representative Reed is the is the
title author
so um
all right so do you want to speak to the
motion very briefly I mean I've already
mentioned um you know what the amendment
does it allows it it lifts any sort of
caps it does rewrite the bill in that
sense
um so IT addresses the questions that I
think representative uh trip had um had
raised I think fundamentally it
um
resolve some of the fairness questions I
think in favor of the of the of the
tenant
um I do think that
um representative chair Lynn you know
certainly raises a question about
um legitimate question about whether or
not that the higher rent might be baked
in that may have the a function of sort
of self-selecting it may actually be
something that that works to the the
landlord's favor in the sense that if
folks see the rent or whatever it is
that may self-select who's who's
applying for for that so it may Whittle
the field a little bit um but it's
pretty straightforward bipartisan
Amendment and I'm hoping that the
committee will will support it thank you
all right yes representative Smith
all right
um anyone else wish to be heard
um all right so uh this is a vote on the
amendment
um uh
do we need to have a uh yes
representative Stapleton yeah
relative to the amendment I have a
problem with
the section that says If a landlord
collects a rental application fee from a
prospective tenant the landlord shall be
obligated to rent the unit to the tenant
provided
passes back criminal background and
credit check
it leaves no
other reason
for a rejection
I've been asked to be a referral for
people who wanted to rent properties
and what if for instance the referrals
report
well he's trashed two other places
or there's some other thing I mean you
can come up with any number of things
that could be valid some could be
invalid but it basically closes out the
option to
um reject on some other cause legitimate
or otherwise and I think that's an
imposition against the freedom that the
landlord should have commercially
uh yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and in response to
that the last sentence of the Amendments
is nothing in this paragraph shall
require the landlord to conduct a
criminal background check and credit
check or prohibit the landlord from
renting to an applicant who does not
pass the criminal background and credit
check so right there if they've trashed
two places that's grounds for saying no
anyone else
um wish to be hurt
all right so um I'm sorry yes
representative Staples
um I I would still say that excludes
um rejection on other cause
and it denies the landlord
the the freedom or the ability to
investigate and act on other causes for
declining the rent
yeah I I I mean I guess I'm I'm sort of
back to the same thing I said you the
the the more you sort of make make
things risky for the landlord I now have
this I have to worry about you know have
I have I complied with this or am I
going to be am I likely to get sued or
something like that because I've
violated this new restrict
they're going to factor that risk into
the work to the rent it seems to me and
it's gonna just be this is not gonna
make housing more available I think it's
going to make it less available but
anyway
um
so
uh rep page had moved the adoption of
the amendment we didn't have us and and
asked for otpa we didn't have somebody
to second that
I thought we actually did but maybe I'm
sorry if I so is there a second
representative Smith's second okay all
right
all right
so are anybody else have anything to say
before we vote on the amendment
all right so then we'll have a roll call
vote on Amendment on the amendment that
was offered by representative creason uh
kutab and Reed I'm sorry read
um
and I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
well that's what no that's what we're
voting on now yeah we're voting on on
whether to adopt the amendment
there's been a request for a roll call
I'm going to do that
Vice chairman Wallace
rep Alexander no
rep Andrews no
rep testerman no
rep Stapleton no
rap trip no
rep Grayson no
Clark could have votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
reporgan no
yes
rep De Lorenzo
rep Eaton yes
yes rep page yes
Rhett Macbeth yes
rep divine
yes
rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes
rep Terror yes
chair chairman Lynn no
motion fails
um
wait
[Music]
10 10. all right so 10 10 the the motion
to a man fails
um
okay all right so now we're back to the
main
bill
foreign
so now we're back to the main uh Bill HB
um
as introduced so is there a motion on
that
is
I move out to pass on the original bill
is introduced is there a second
so so
your motion is OTP representative I'm
sorry who wrote moved to representative
all right all right what's wrong so so
there's been a motion made by
representative Horrigan uh to OTP House
Bill 283 in its original version is
there a second to that motion
seeing no second the most oh I'm sorry
representative Devine you second all
right so the motion has been made and
seconded uh to adopt uh House Bill 283
as originally presented to us does
anyone wish to speak to the motion
representative organ it's just I just uh
think the original bill was simpler more
workable than the than the amendment
although I have mixed feelings about how
the vote on that one went but I think
this I think what they came in with the
first was the right way to address the
issue so that's why I'm trying to bring
back the original bills
uh representative Tripp
uh I'm gonna say the same thing I said
before
uh if the background check came back
with something uh that required further
investigation that would be an initial
charge and uh right now the charge is
limited to 35 dollars uh in the other
instance uh
if uh the application fees can't uh
exceed 250 dollars if uh this bill
sticks around if this law sticks around
for a while I'm sure inflation will
cause the application fees to be in
excess of 250 dollars
anyone else wish to speak on the yes
representative divine
I just think there's a lot of potential
for landlords to
take in a lot especially with the market
the way it's going rental property is
going to be in demand and
um 35 dollars a whack for everybody
that's competing for
limited property or limited rentals
um it just seems like
it shouldn't even be there 35 shouldn't
even be there it shouldn't even be this
is this is illegal in other states I
don't know why it's still legal here in
this state but for landlords I just
don't think it's it's the right thing I
think you know this at least limits it
and gives
um potential tenants or people who are
looking for a prop um rental
unit
um you know some basis to not get gouged
by
fees right anyone else have any
any anything I want to say all right so
the motion on the floor is ought to pass
House Bill 283 in its original form uh
I'd ask the uh clerk to call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rev
testerman rep Stapleton no reptrip no
rep Grayson no
clerkutab votes no rep Perez
no
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yes rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes
rep Divine yes
rep Lanza yes Brett Manos
no
bacteria uh no
chairman Lynn no
motion fails age 12.
8 OTP fails
with a motion to reconsider the vote on
the amendment be in order at this time
as I understand it
um
okay motion emotion can be made
you don't have to be in the majority or
the minority you motion to reconsider
can be made okay so I like to reconsider
the vote on the amendment which I
believe was 420 422 h
is there a second
all seconded out of courtesy but I have
a question so are we just voting if it's
okay to reconsider right now
or are we actually reconsidering we're
voting I'll take a second vote in the
amendment voting as to whether or not we
should reconsider and then if we vote
that we should then we will vote on what
the reconsideration will be
uh all second is a courtesy to my
colleague
so motion to reconsider it has been made
and seconded um
I think in since we've had roll call
votes on everything else we should have
a roll call vote on this is any does it
before we do that however does anybody
have anything else that they wish to say
on the motion to reconsider
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
whoop sorry yes representative Manos
Julie but I would like to see us we did
have some bipartisan discussion about
this bill
um in terms of drafting an amendment the
amendment that failed
um so I would like to see us retain this
to see if we could continue to work
toward a bipartisan solution to it
well okay so uh but let me just I mean
we have a motion that's been made and
seconded to reconsider
um representative Horrigan would you be
willing uh to to withdraw your motion
just for the moment so we can have a
discussion uh a a discussion along the
lines of what representative Manna said
I would certainly allow you to make the
motion again
um
pardon
definitely tell us why the routine just
preferable it's like sure yeah why don't
you representative Manos what do you why
do you think that's thank you Mr chair
um we did have some bipartisan or
um bipartisan discussion among
colleagues on
um the amendment that failed and I'm
hopeful that if we retain this that we
can continue to have discussions that
would enable us to uh further amend the
bills so that it would be acceptable to
the majority of the committee and that
would be my goal
so
um
you do so in light of that uh
representative Horrigan do you want to
amend your motion or do you still want
to go with the motion to reconsider
well I think I'll go with the motion to
reconsider and then we'll all right all
right so has uh that I think that motion
has has that motion been seconded yeah
it has been a few seconds I'm sorry all
right so anybody want to just further
discuss representative horrigan's motion
to reconsider the vote on the amendment
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews no
rep testerman
rep Stapleton no
rap trip no
rep Grayson no
kirkutab votes yes
rep Perez no
rep Smith
yes
reporgan yes
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton yeah
Brett page yes
Brett Macbeth
no
rep Divine yes
rep Lanza yes
rep Manos
yes
repturer yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 12-8
all right so now
we are back to the question of voting on
the amendment
um so I I would I'm
doing this in the hopes of being able to
vote for the amendment because the
original bill was rejected by a majority
of the committee whereas this one has a
better chance of
the oath getting to the floor that was
uh so
that's
so both of them are great there's a
motion to there's a motion now
to vote on the amendment that had that
had failed before is that motion
seconded
all right so uh representative Smith
seconds that motion
anyone want to have further discussion
on the motion
all right assistant
this is on the amendment so all right so
while we were so I'm we're ready for the
question then I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on uh on the amendment
um
422h of whether we should uh adopt the
immense
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander
rep Andrews no
rep testerman oh
rep Stapleton no prep trip no
rep Grayson no
clerkutab votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes
rep eaten
rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes rep
Divine yes rep blanza yes rep Manos yes
repterra yes
chairman Lynn no
motion veils 10 to 10.
Mr chair yes I move that we retain
uh House Bill 283
um I I think that there's an attempt to
to work with this at least as far as the
amendment goes the underlying bill I
can't support and and would not want to
work with that as a template but at
least the amendment is someplace where
we found some common ground but I do see
where it could be problematic
there's a problem that does appear to
need to be solved and that is the excuse
me the collection of fees by landlords
uh when there appears to be no attempt
to to lease out a a unit and then there
are these holding fees that we heard
about that could run into the thousands
or somewhere around a thousand dollars
or more and these fun these fees are not
refunded it's all big questions that are
left unanswered and so because there is
something that that uh there appears to
be something bubbling out there uh an
attempt is being made to address that
this just may not be the right way so
what if we retain it and see if we can't
address that and if we fail I also be it
I won't lose any sleep
all right um so it's there um so there's
so are you making a motion to retain I
did okay and is there a second
one second representative Manos uh
seconds
um
any further uh discussion on the yes
representative Alexander um thank you Mr
chair I think this is another assault on
free markets and landlords and I don't
even think of retain would get me to a
yes but I'm seeing where the the votes
are going so thank you all right
um anyone else wish to comment I have to
say I'm I'm with representative
Alexander I think that this is not a
good idea but
I think you're putting landlords in a
position that they're going to just
raise their credit limits and do things
that they don't normally wouldn't
normally do so that they have a choice
of who they're renting to they're going
to end up having to
change things for different people and
it's just putting them in a very very
bad position you know can I can I just
this whenever he's just a person a
procedural issue here
um
we um
we're
we're back to the
um
the the amendments there so we're we're
back to
um
280 283 as it is
to to retain
um
yeah okay so yeah that's the issue so do
we want uh is anyone else there's been a
motion made Mr Kia yes I just I would
just like to make some comments
certainly okay well thank you Mr chair
you know
um I'm not comfortable with the way this
bill is going in our response to the
bill
um there's been a lot of speculations
about what landlords will do what they
won't do we talk about inflation I've
never seen inflation raise a um
an application fee that would be
granular I mean inflation goes up what
eight percent you're gonna
increase your um application fee eight
percent I don't think landlines have
time for that
um so I feel like we need some expert
advice here and not speculation
um because we're I think we're getting
into that I don't know the
the dunders or something
um and we're not making sense you know
we're not basing things on science or
experience or anything else like that
thank you
so
yes representative tur
yeah the idea of retaining seems
appropriate to me given that you know
two of the members that sort of are not
supporting the amendment are named on
the amendment and it feels as though
they want to making the motion
um see a way forward or a possible way
forward with this bill
um and uh you know in response to the
question of landlords not being able to
rent to who they want to I just don't
see that in this bill it almost
simplifies their world because
they essentially will choose the person
they want and then that's who they will
collect the the application fee from
Once the decisions
um in place so it feels like it solves
the problem of of rampant uh un you know
productive application fees that cost
people a lot of money while also you
know sort of streamlining the whole
process for the landlords as well in my
opinion so for both of those reasons I
like the idea
all right
so
yeah all right all right so the anyone
else wish to be heard on the motion to
retain
all right so the the question before the
committee then is motion to retain House
Bill 283 and I'd ask the clerk to call
the uh the roll please Vice chairman
Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rap trip
nope rap Grayson yes
clerk could have votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eden yes
rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
repturer yes
chairman Lynn no
motion passes 11 to 9.
all right
11 to 9 routine all right
all right yeah yes all right uh thank
you all for your for your Indulgence on
this that uh we had a we had a good
discussion all right
moving on to House Bill 401 relative to
evictions based on the owner's intent uh
to uh
uh
renovate
um recognize the chair recognizes
representative Perez for a motion thank
you chair um I would like to move that
this bill 401 be itl'd all right is
there a second seconded by
representative Wallace representative
Perez would you like to speak to your
motion yes there's several things that
concern me um I don't have a problem
with um the fact that if I want to
renovate my unit that I have to give my
tenant 60 days notice I don't have a
problem with the fact that I would have
to let them know what the repairs were
going to do we're going to do I do have
a problem that I probably will not be
able to give them a time frame because
who knows when you can get someone I but
what I have a most problem with is if
I'm renovating to this limits my ability
to renovate to take something off the
market or to perhaps stop you know stop
renting it out or to sell
um
it establishes discretionary stay of up
to six months it says that uh
it can't be returned to the retail
Market within 12 months if it does then
of the 10 the um there's liability
involved with it I just think it's
um it just it just limits again
the ability of the landlord
the owner of the property to do what
they feel is right or need to do
for their own property
right anyone else wish to be heard on
House Bill 401.
all right
um
so the the question before us is that
then is on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 401 and I would
ask the clerk to call the roll please
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Anders yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes
clerk routab votes yes Brett Perez yes
rep Smith
reporgan no Reptil Lorenzo no rep Eaton
rep page no Brett Macbeth no rep Divine
no rap lonza no Brett Manos
no rapture
no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10. is there another
emotion
see
the ideology just lost so then hard to
pass as an alternative
uh well is is there I mean I guess you
don't have to make a motion of of uh of
ought to pass it would
it would go to the floor with no record
you know with with no recommendation
whether we I think whether we make
whether there's a motion ought to pass
or not um but it wouldn't have a report
but it wouldn't have a report that's
right
even if there's no motion for ought to
pass yes
correct there would be a report
on each side
oh okay all right I'm going to make the
motion not to pass just so that the
search will be there yeah second sure
all right so there's so uh motion of
ought to pass has been made and seconded
to either uh representative McMaster
representative Morgan do you wish to
speak to your motion
I just think um why co-sponsors this
bill so obviously I liked it I still
like it and um
it's a my opinion probably doesn't go
far enough like there's not much in the
way it guarantees that the renovations
will actually be done but I think um and
if the landlord's concerned about
selling the property and then getting
hit with somebody getting hit with a ten
thousand dollar uh penalty uh well first
of all you can avoid that by doing your
due diligence if you're the buyer
because that's one of the encumbrances
on the property you have to ask about
and of course it's a perfective seller
also has the option of um getting the
notebook or so that's not always easy
but getting the tenants to leave
voluntarily like certainly probably most
tenants would probably move out if
you're offered them ten thousand dollars
for example but um so I think I know not
everybody's totally satisfied at the
bill but I think this is a step forward
and we should pass it as is that all
right anybody else wish to be heard on
uh the motion of ought to pass
seeing none I guess we're ready for the
question then I asked the clerk to call
the roll on uh House Bill 401 the motion
being ought to pass
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no
rep Andrews no rap testerman
rep Stapleton no rap trap no rap Grayson
no quirkuta votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton
yes
yes rep page yes Rhett Macbeth yes rep
Divine yes rep Lanza
yes we're at Manos yes rep Terror
yes
chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
all right so this um
is there any other emotions
all right seeing none so this will go to
the floor
um without uh recommendation
um representative Perez lets you to
write the report for itl and who will
write the report for OTP
do cam cam Kenny
all right
uh I don't think so he wasn't good about
he could speak on the floor okay but I
don't think he can ride there
so all right
all right Smith but Wilson we can
certainly consult with Cam or anybody
else we want any other experts we want
to before right now thanks all right
great all right
so moving on then to House Bill 469
prohibiting discrimination
against tenants holding certain vouchers
for purposes of renting dwellings the
chair recognized representative kutab
for a motion
I move itl their second
Ed by representative Wallace
representative qatab do you wish to
speak to your motion
I found the testimony from the landlords
that
they're able to decide to take them or
not and some of them have formulas that
they use on a basis because it is a risk
to them if they do take the voucher that
the tenant can do a midnight move out
and they're not guaranteed those funds
if they do that and so several of the
you know landlords had mentioned that
sometimes they're willing to take that
risk risk for a few of the units but
they don't want it to be for you know
necessarily all of the units in their
home and it seemed like what the real
underlying issue was was obviously a
housing Supply but also it was mentioned
that the person who was receiving the
voucher only had 60 days to find a
property after sometimes waiting for 10
years
it seems like the real problem is is
that they should have a longer period of
time to find and that's you know what
should perhaps be fixed and not
forcing the landlords to take something
or not because it does put a lot of
regulations on to them and not all of
them
perhaps want to do that it should be
their choice it's it's their property
anyone else wish to be heard
on House Bill uh 469 the motion Ito yes
representative horde well I think we'll
turn the Section 8 program there aren't
there's the supply of vouchers is vastly
insufficient and so the way the market
is in this particular Market in this
region that waiting period is kind of
not very useful although on the other
hand
um there are some landlords who
specialize in subsidized federally
subsidized housing some of which are
even for profit companies so that is a
market that uh
some entities actually do serve and
prefer to serve and the uh the tenants
have um you know you have a third party
in the contract which complicates thing
and it's a third party the federal
government which is the same size as the
landlord are actually probably most
cases bigger
well the federal government is backing
up a Housing Authority so you know it is
uh does become a more even you know the
power structure is more evenly
structured but the things that the
Housing Authority are at demanding of
the tenants and the landlords
I actually read tried to read read all
the regulations I mean it is a pretty
good sleep aid if you suffer from
insomnia if you're losing sleep over
anything that happened here today but
it's um
there's nothing in there that I think is
terribly unreasonable those are like
rights and responsibilities that uh
should be taken for granted in any
landlord-10 relationship and the only
real difference here is that you have an
entity actually making sure that the
parties live up to the agreement and
otherwise it's kind of like the wild
west as we've as we've heard and um
and also I think in the future we may be
moving to more subsidized housing
because like even with the rents
as high as they are at the vacancy rate
non-existent um there's still not much I
mean there's some new rental property
being built but not enough and uh
at least to believe
the advocates for the private landlords
are just barely you know hanging on you
know like if you have inflation or the
boiler going out or whatever then it's a
disaster you know they don't seem to
have they seem to feel they have no
margin for errors we may have to go to
more subsidized housing in the future
anyways I think this is a
um Section 8 is a good program it
probably needs to be tweaked certainly
needs to be expanded but um I think um
I don't think landlords should be
allowed to discriminate against the uh
people who are holding the vouchers and
of course especially a lot of them
they're like me from a local
socioeconomic class they may be uh
different from the other renters and
other ways visible or invisible but they
have the same rights as everyone else
they shouldn't be discriminating in just
on that basis so I recommend voting no
in the itl and then voting yes on the
subsequent ought to pass all right
thanks thank you representative
representative Macbeth thank you I think
I have the right bill I I think this
bill it didn't require landlords to do
anything except not say no that they
wouldn't accept them so I you know you
can't
um you can't like what you don't see and
I just um I thought it was a good good
requirement just to allow anybody to
apply it's an open it's a free market
so instead of saying no certain people
can't apply this would allow free market
everybody gets to apply no no commitment
on the landlord no requirement that they
Grant a certain amount or anything just
that it's a free market and everybody
gets to submit their application so
thank you other yes representative
greeson
thank you Mr chair something that uh
I've not heard yet brought up that uh
that came to mind is that insurance
companies will often look at how many
section eight uh tenants you have and
that can play a role on your
insurability or your or your premiums
and may or may not I don't know what
those are but we would end up having to
go into insurance laws and make sure
there are no conflicts in there if
anything would have to be modified over
that section so that just opens up a
huge can of worms if if this bill were
to pass so I would have to oppose it uh
just based on its current uh uh reading
just based on
this this becomes uh problematic all
right representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair this is this is a bill that
would
um penalize landlords if they refuse to
rent not refuse to take an application
but refuse to make a rental
um to a person holding a Section 8
voucher
um Section 8 vouchers require that a
landlord follows over 70 pages of
regulations and
um my friend representative Horrigan
said he's fall asleep at those
regulations I mean I couldn't imagine
having to read all those pages and
follow all those extra regulations and
um so this is a rental refusal this is
just an assault on landlords they have a
right to allow anybody to rent rent to
anybody and and um this bill is just
another regulation we don't need
representative Smith
thank you um I'm not a hundred percent
sure that representative Alexander was
completely
um accurate in what landlords can and
can't do but my question really is for
representative greeson this is a whole
new area for me I wonder if you could
give me the documentation or the
citations that indicate that
title eight
um
a tenants costs more in terms of
insurance I would have thought it would
go the other way since there's a
guarantee that the rent's going to be
paid which is better than not having
that guarantee so I need your advice
representative Greece my advice is read
the laws I said I don't know what the
impact would be they may go up they may
not go up I'm saying I don't know but it
opens up the question about insurance
insurability I don't know if it will or
not I see okay I was I misunderstood you
I thought what you were saying is that
yes it would increase the rates and
thank you for that clarification I
really appreciate it all right if I
should oh yes representative D Lorenzo
please you know I've been a landlord at
the landlord for 35 years I my companies
that I worked for we took Section 8
vouchers
um I was heavily involved in the
financing of our properties the
operations the accounting
um audits by the government
private Audits and I have never ever
ever heard that um insurance rates
tend to increase when landlines accept
vouchers Section 8 vouchers or any other
kind of subsidies so
um that's just not true
thank you anybody else have anything to
say on House Bill 469 the motion before
us is uh you know speeding to legislate
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
the roll Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrick yes rep
Grayson yes clerkutab yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
reporter again no reptilorenzo
no rep Eaton
prep page no Brett Macbeth no rep Divine
no replanza no rep Manos
no ripped here no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10.
is there another motion
no one else I'll bring forward an OTP
all right is there a second
by representative Macbeth
anybody wish to be heard further on this
motion
seeing none I think we're ready to call
the roll on the motion now is ought to
pass on House Bill 469.
ask the clerk to call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace no
Alexander no rep Andrews no prep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rap trip
no rep Grayson no
clerk who tab votes no rep Perez no rep
Smith
yes reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yes
yes rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes rep
Divine YES Prep lonza yes rep Manos yes
repter yes chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
[Laughter]
all right
um
so
so uh
representative kutaba had asked you to
write the report in favor of itl and who
will write the report in favor of OTP
um well I made the Motions I guess I'll
do it probably all right all right
probably in a close consultation with my
other two committee members and
representative Oregon
the report of ought to pass
yes please
all right so next
um we will turn to
um
House Bill 567 relative to notice of
rent increases in uh certain residential
rental property and I'd recognize
representative cutoff for a motion
I move itl is there a second seconded by
representative Wallace representative
Qatar would you like to speak to your
emotion
and say take your time no you've got a
million pieces of paper in front of you
take your time take your time
I believe that this is just putting
unnecessary controls onto the free
market I think that six months is an
excessively long amount of time it's
very difficult to plan what's going to
happen six months out I recently I think
we all recently had our electric rates
go up as well as our you know home
heating rates and that was something
that couldn't necessarily be predicted
six months in advance and so I think
it's putting kind of an unnecessary
burden on landlords to predict what
something may or may not
be going up so
I think we have a big housing shortage
and trying to further restrict the
market is going to have a detrimental
effect on it
all right
um anyone other people wish to be heard
on House Bill 567.
all right are you ready for the question
right then the the motion before us is
uh in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 567 and I would ask the clerk
police to call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
okay rep Andrews yes
rep testerman
Rob Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes
Clark kutab votes yes
rep Perez
yes
rep Smith
no
reporter again no
rep dilorenzo no rep Eden
wrap page no
Brett Macbeth no
grip Divine no rap Lanza no
we're at Manos no rapture
no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails nine to ten
right
okay
there we go
so the itl ten to nine
to ten I'm sorry nine to ten
itl fails
um
is there another motion
representative
yes
thank you Mr chair I have a an amendment
that I have circulated uh to the bill
and I would like to propose the
amendment I think so you're moving otpa
yes CTA yeah thank you let me get the
hang on one second we uh I think we have
that right hang on one second yes five
share a second
of
yeah I'm sorry is there a second on the
motion
seconds
567 hang on
what sorry could you tell me the
amendment number one more time please uh
yes unfortunately zero two three zero
four two nine h
m
all right and um so the emotion the
amendment motion to amend has been made
and seconded
um representative Maris would you like
to speak to your motion please I would
Mr chair thank you
um
the amendment that I have proposed
addresses some of the points that
representative catawb made it would
restrict to 60 days the notice of rent
increase rather than the
proposed
six months it also eliminates paragraph
Roman numeral three
which would have given
tenants the right to terminate their
existing lease with 10 days notice
and so I think the amendment is
um addresses the concerns that have been
noted
um about this bill
all right anyone else wish to wish to
speak with regard to this I'm sorry
representative
uh yeah just I I think the removal
particularly of section three uh to me
really strengthens the the bill by
removing what I what I think would not
have even been a probably ultimately
legal requirement to terminate at least
just based on a notice that in some
future time the the rent after the lease
would be increased so
I'm hoping we'll have a chance to talk
about the bill as amended
all right
um anyone else wish to speak so I guess
I would just say it just I mean I I
would I repeat what I said before the
more of these kind of restrictions you
place on landlords to the more you make
a housing unavailable at least to some
extent or or the rent goes up so I I
don't think that the thank you I will
not be supporting the the amendment
all right are we anyone else wish to
speak
yes representative Perez what if I pay
the utilities on this apartment I pay
the electric and I pay the heating
utilities my electric and heating has
gone up far more than 15 percent and
um I think and my on top of that
um my um
assessment on my house has gone up and
my taxes have gone up more than 15 we
need to take that in consideration when
we're setting a cap on landlords
all right
um all right anyone else wish to speak
can we just yeah oh I'm sorry yes
Representative no I was just saying I I
don't see that this sets a cap per se it
just sets a notification require
requirement for reading it right all
right anyone else wish to speak all
right so the the Whoop I'm sorry Mr
representative Stapleton
oh thank you Mr chair um
I think the six months written notice of
intended rent increases so egregious
that
um the the amendment
um
removes that and I think that's a good
thing I
kind of be inclined to um
accept the amendment if maybe I didn't
even accept the bill
can I ask a question I just want to make
sure I'm understanding so I see that the
amendment is replacing section one which
I if my memory serves me correct was
relative to the notice but there was a
another section relative to the tenant
and
giving notice to vacate is that correct
yeah when it says section one it really
means this so that's all the way down to
the that's everything except the
effective date right is that the correct
representative I believe so see what I
mean in other words it so it says
um
a man R6 as inserted by section one of
the bill by replacing it with the
following so as I understand
your Amendment it replaces all of
section one
of the bill which really is everything
except the effective down to the
effective date
okay so it does so it does replace this
part too
it replaces Roman numeral one Roman
numeral two and Roman numeral three so
it's no longer
um
saying that the tenant can
terminate the lease with 10 days notice
anymore it's just saying you have to
give a notice but there's no more they
can leave in 10 days correct okay
um anyone else wish to be heard on this
right seeing no one uh so the the
um the question before us then is on uh
representative manos's uh Amendment
2023-429 H
um
and I guess we'll we'll have a roll call
vote on the amendment
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no
rep Stapleton yes
rep trip no
rep Grayson no
Clark kutab votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes
prep De Lorenzo yes rep Eaton yes rep
page yes Brett Macbeth YES Prep Devine
yes rep Lanza yes Brett Manos yes
reptario yes
chairman Lynn no
motion passes 11 to 9.
all right
so now we are on to
the main bill as amended so it's
uh 567
uh otpa as amended by representative uh
manis's Amendment does anybody wish to
speak further on that bill
seeing none are we ready for the
question all right so then the the uh
motion before us is otpa on the bill as
amended and I would ask uh the clerk to
please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman
no
rep Stapleton no reptrip no rep Grayson
clerkutab votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
reporgan yes rep dilorenzo yes rep Eaton
yes
yes rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes rep
Divine YES Prep lonza yes
rep Manos yes reptile yes
chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
um
all right so
yes I guess it'll go to the floor
um without recommendation and so
um
uh representative would you write the
report uh in favor of itl and who will
write the report in favor of uh otpa
I believe the the motion on the floor is
going to be it's otpa but the first
motion is OTP right
so the amendment would have to be
approved again on the floor am I right
that's right it would have to be
approved yeah sure yeah yeah you know
you're right you're right um
all right
um
GL and
uh Manos is going to write the report
stuff
they ask us do we do we have to have a
vote on the itl or can we just go ahead
and no we already yeah we voted on the
itl and it failed it failed yeah so
um but uh 235 on a consent calendar
for for OPC
right oh yeah you know what rep uh yeah
that's that's no exactly so let me just
ask I'm sorry to do this but let me
representative Wallace brings up a valid
point on HP 235
which we uh that's on the uh
committee now to study expansion of the
landlord Senate mediation can is there
any reason that can't go on the consent
calendar anybody object to that being on
the consent calendar
yeah 18-1 ought to pass
okay yeah all right
it is 100 all right all right
um
so hang on one second
yes
of course absolutely it's regarding the
amendment number
or
the reason this morning
features hb162 what is the correct
she has 162.75.
uh what's up
foreign
let me see uh
the
162 the proper amendment that
is
116 h on 162.
116 h
M yeah all right so
um now we are up to
um house bill
641 and
hang on one second
um
all right all right so and uh yeah that
was Joe and uh Kate
okay so Joy yeah yeah yeah all right so
all right so um
on House Bill
um 641 I'd recognize representative
Alexander for a motion thank you Mr
chair
um I moved to retain hb641
is there a second I second
all right representative Alexander would
you like to speak to your motion um yes
Mr chair I'm actually a real glutton for
punishment and I like to spend the
summer months in this committee room
with a small subcommittee working on
this bill
um it's clear that there's some work we
can do I think DHHS came in and gave us
very important information regarding the
clearance reports
um regarding the lead inspectors how
they're paid how long it takes the
clearance report
um how long they have to turn it over
DHHS indicated there's some wiggle room
there such as moving the um required
date from 14 days to 30 days
um and then on top of that I have an
amendment floating around that I think
is a good Amendment but there's still
like a lot of stuff up in the air
regarding this bill and I think that
maybe
um unlike other bills we've had today
this committee could actually sit down
and come up with something and if we
can't we can't I get it but I'd kind of
like to learn more about how lead
inspectors are paid so
um I hope the committee will vote with
me on this thanks representative Qatar
I I second a lot of what rep Alexander
just said and I just wanted to also
mention that HHS had made comment that
they were willing to get together with
the lead inspectors as well and try and
you know perhaps find a compromise
for a solution on the rules so that it
wouldn't necessarily have to take uh
legislation and so I think it's worth
retaining it and seeing if they're able
to come to a compromise and if they're
not then perhaps we go the legislative
route so
anyone else have any yes representative
Alexander yeah just to add to that I I
think it's important that we encourage
that behavior and then hold on to this
bill just to make sure that that
conversation is happening because I
think this is a real opportunity for it
to be solved in the regulatory
the bureaucracy but I like you know the
general card to have a play that if we
can so I'd like to be a maybe even a
mediator in the process thanks
all right anyone else wish to be heard
on this representative Manos
I'd appreciate appreciate us being
reminded I I'm not remembering the
testimony of lead paint inspectors who
hadn't been paid and that this was
problematic so if other members would
remind me of that testimony I would
appreciate it well
let me I I will I will respond with my
recollection of what I heard other
people may have a different View and I
want to emphasize here I am going to
vote to retain with uh for the reasons
that Alexander representative Alexander
and representative cutoff have stated
but
I have to say
that the testimony that I heard
suggested to me that there is one
inspector
who was having trouble getting paid
and could have
demanded as apparently other lead
inspectors do could have demanded a
deposit up front and would have and so I
I'm
I hope we will be able to come to some
resolution that will you know make
things better in terms of the the
relationship between lead inspectors and
the Department of Health and Human
Services
I can't help having the the the the
taste in my mouth that this
um this proposal is designed to sort of
put the legislature in the business of
helping a creditor who could easily have
helped herself by simply getting a
deposit up front and I'm not sure we
ought to be doing that but nonetheless
maybe there are other things you know
that as as representative Alexander and
kutab point out maybe there are other
things that we can that you know need
are worth doing and I'm perfectly fine
with retaining with retaining the bill
um but I guess I would say that there
will be a it will take a lot to convince
me in the fall
that we ought to be in the business of
of you know legislating to sort of
help
um help a
a business person collect on a debt that
they could easily have protected
themselves and collected on on their own
that's my view other people may have a
different View
yes representative Staples
yeah I I share that particular aspect of
the view that the legislature shouldn't
be in the position of
mandating something that could otherwise
be handled properly with other remedy
the deposit for instance is there any
prohibition against deposits
um or retainers for these things I mean
how much are these fees for lead
inspection do they run a Gambit of so
many dollars to hundreds or what you
where where are we at with that
my understanding is they can be quite
expensive but as but I believe as we
heard at some point that apparently
there are other inspectors who do get
security deposits um you know up front
of of some percentage or maybe all of
the so anyway
yeah yes representative work I was uh
well when my uh
when my mother sold uh the house she has
a father we had to go through a lead
inspection process for that sale and um
as far as you know we paid it we paid
the fee with out any drama but like in
that case that's part of the case in all
cases it was in both parties interest to
get that issue resolved as soon as
possible the family bought the house
wanted
move in as soon as possible in my uh
what their course wanted to sell it and
collect money as soon as possible so I'm
not sure
why this is happening except
occasionally if you just get an
irresponsible uh seller or buyer
involved so yeah so you know I guess I
want to say though it's I I mean I I do
have the frustration that I just pointed
out but I I do think that uh
representative Alexander and kutab have
a a really valid point that it appears
that
there are some issues at the Department
of Health and Human Services that you
know
maybe could be sort of addressed better
and so retaining it I think probably
does make some make some sense if it
turns out in the fall that you know
nothing has changed then I know what my
vote will be but maybe maybe we will get
some additional information
and thank you Mr chair I've I had a
private conversation with members in
this room from DHHS and they're
comfortable with retaining as well in
order to have a conversation
um and maybe we can facilitate the
conversation between the two or or you
know sure work on it so
can I ask one quick clarify of course
yes a lot of the conversation when the
bill was heard
um revolved around an amendment that was
offered
um by representative Kelly Hillsborough
um so I don't know is that is that
incorporated into what what you were
thinking
um yeah I I planned on I actually I have
an amendment I circulated earlier that
um I think would completely replace
representative Kelly's bill but add some
things to it um so I I mean the the bill
is introduced is a mess
um in my opinion but I think that the
Amendments kind of get us closer where
we need to be so I'm not interested in
the amendment because I want to look at
that in the retention process okay yeah
I agree with the statements that it
probably could be avoided altogether and
it's fairly narrow but in the name of
giving you something to do over the
summer sure
we don't want you to be bored
representative Alexander
all right so um the motion the motion
before us is to retain it's been moved
and seconded is there any further
discussion on the motion
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
please call the roll Vice chairman
Wallace yes rep Alexander yes rep
Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton no
trap trip yes
rep Grayson yes
clerkutab yes Brett Perez yes
rep Smith
reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton
yes
rep page
Brett Macbeth
yes
rep Divine no
replanza yes
rep Manos
yes
wrapped her yes
chairman Lynn yes with a sigh
motion passes 18 to 2. Mr chair I invite
anybody that voted yes to sit with me on
a subcommittee I'm sure I'll be in
charge
um please feel free to reach out all
right and Mr chair does this mean that
representative Stapleton and devine
don't have to sit on that committee
that's right that's right yes
[Laughter]
all right all right
um
all right um moving on to uh
House Bill 362
relating to the procedures before the
human rights uh
commission
um
right is there a second to that
representative Staples in seconds
representative Smith would you like to
speak to the motion
no but I will fear myself oh your mic's
off representative Smith thank you thank
you I don't imagine anyone really wants
to hear me anymore
um I'm moving to retain this bill
um
the situation
at the Human Rights Commission is very
complicated
um the bill that we have before ours had
come from the Senate last term we worked
a lot on the issues over the summer
we came up with um
Bill to address one very small problem
and it's only a small problem when there
are many other problems
since
um the term began
The Joint
legislative committee on performance
audits has met
and decided to do a thorough performance
audit of the commission
that what a request was sent to the
fiscal committee which agreed
that
causes me to suggest
that we would be more responsible
by voting to retain this bill now
letting
um the uh the LBA audit division do
their magic
and also giving many
concerned individuals and institutions
outside of the legislature time to talk
with us about ways that we might
really
improve what is happening at the
commission
um and therefore I would urge the
committee to support the retention
motion
anyone else wish to be heard
um I'm I'm uh I guess I am going to vote
for the retention motion I joined uh
much of what representative
Smith has said
um I think it will be helpful to hear
what the what the uh
what the audit has to say I'm not sure I
don't know whether we'll have that by
the time we have to make some decision
but but hopefully we will and the other
thing I guess I would say on this is
it it really does seem like
there are a lot of issues with respect
to the Human Rights Commission and the
proposed bill
um
really doesn't address any of those
things it it does
you know it it in one sense it does it
does solve a problem that the the the
people who testified in favor of it
um uh rays which is is there science is
it unfair to allow a respondent to
remove a case after a finding of
probable cause is made particularly when
it often takes years for that product of
finding a probable cause to have been
arrived at which
it's hard to understand how that happens
but it does
um
so I um but that doesn't really deal
with the whole issue of why does it take
so long
um
I personally happen to think that there
was that that although that might make
it fairer
to claimants to remove as that as the
bill proposes to do the respondents
right to make any
um to remove
um is is not fair to respondents and so
I had proposed an amendment that would
have made would have allowed respondents
to to make uh to make motions to remove
but it would have to do it very quickly
after the 180 day period expired
that seemed to me to be a little fairer
to both to both sides correct the
problem that the plaintiffs were
complaining about but give make it
fairer to the respondents but I have to
acknowledge that
maybe that's not the best way either
maybe there are better ways to do this
that would be fair you know that would
be more even more fair to both sides and
um I think for all those reasons I think
that
um what what representative Smith
proposes makes a lot of sense and so I
plan to vote to retain yes
representative Tripp uh thank you chair
uh I'm new to this committee but uh it
piques my interest that we are retaining
so many bills is this something that's
common practice in judiciary
yeah um I would the answer to that is no
I think there are a number of reasons
why we are retaining so many bills this
time
um and to tell you the truth I believe
one of the reasons
it has to do with the physical plant the
fact that we now have uh half as many
committee rooms as we've had in the past
means that we have to share committee
rooms with people and therefore we do
not have the opportunity to have work
sessions the way for all the previous
years that I've been in the legislature
we were able to take bills and spend
time in work sessions to try to
to solve the problems so and so that's
that is one reason another reason is the
very practical reason representative
Tripp that when the voters of New
Hampshire
sent us to this particular legislature
um they they either made the whys or the
unwise decision of having us and I'm not
ready to vote on that one yet to have a
very close number of uh Democrats and
Republicans as you can see on many of
the bills we have not taken
uh
partisan votes on many of the bills
we've agreed either itl or OTP the few
bills where
um and it's the minority of the bills
we've had where we haven't been able to
reach
um agreement we could go to the floor
with
um no recommendation
but it seems somehow more responsible to
keep the bill here until we can see if
maybe we can come up with an agreement
so the reasons both of physical plant
and of party
distribution I think means that in this
committee and in many others we're going
to see more retained bills this year
than usual
well
all I have to say is you had me at the
physical plant thing if you're not able
to hold workshops and obviously that we
have to have some means of continuing to
work on the bill
so retaining is the alternate
alternative thank you
any other comments on the motion to
retain on House Bill uh 362.
so we ready for a vote but I would ask
the uh clerk to please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes clerkutab votes yes rep
Perez
rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep
Delorenzo yes rep Eaton yes Brett page
yes
Brett Macbeth yes rep Divine yes rep
wanza yes we're at Manos yes repter yes
chairman Lynn yes
unanimously 20-0
I know I know I'm sorry
um all right
um so the next with regard to House Bill
um
uh we're I'm I'm gonna uh
defer uh having uh uh any vote on that
uh now it suggests that we have a work
session there are
um
there are uh some I guess what I would
say is is this and I'm just I'm
reflecting my own sort of
view on this bill other people may have
different views but one of the things
that concerned me about the bill
was that it proposed to give the
Department of Education the authority to
and prosecution is probably the wrong
word but to bring
to bring claims
before another agency the Human Rights
Commission
um
on its own the Department of Education
could do that on its own and apparently
although I'm not sure the bill
necessarily had to be read this way but
apparently all the people who were
testifying were reading it this way that
the Department of Education could bring
such a claim before the Human Rights
Commission whether or not the alleged
victim agreed that this could happen
um
that kind of concerned me because as I
understand it would be the only state
agency other than the Department of
Justice that would have that power I've
not quite sure I understand why that
would make sense to give one particular
agency that power particularly when I
went and literally read the statute
yesterday
354a specifically gives the Department
of Justice the authority to do that
whether or not there is a complainant
that agrees so the Department of Justice
can do that
on its own
um and that you know I'm not sure why
that's not sufficient
apparently as I understand it there is
some
there's there's at least been a
suggestion that the Department of
Justice
either doesn't think it has the
authority to do that or is reluctant to
do that for some reason
um I don't know but but
the Department of Education has asked
for some time to try to work something
out with the Department of Justice
um and maybe other people who have an
interest and to come back to us with
some you know with hopefully a proposed
agreement on how uh they might be able
to uh to deal with this
um uh which
that you know if if if there's a
possibility of coming up with a with a
uh something that everybody is kind of
on board with I don't see any reason not
to do that this is not an early bill
um
uh so that's why I um I I
um I'm in favor of of you know giving
them a little more time to do that and
we'll see where we'll see what happens
sure I think that's a decision that you
have the power to make and so there's no
need to discuss that you have the power
to decide when we will accept on bills
so we can just move on to the next one
all right great all right
um
uh House Bill 543 relative to
discrimination against veterans and
price discrimination among other
protected classes the chair recognized
representative testerman for a motion
I make a motion that we ital this bill
is there a second I'll second that Mr
seconded by representative greeson
representative testerman do you wish to
speak to your motion uh just very
shortly uh these kind of bills and I'm a
20-plus year veteran
I just find a lot of these things
obnoxious and a lot of other things I
don't believe that you know we are being
mistreated as veterans I find you know
being put into a list of people who do
think they're being mistreated about
something is really offensive to me so I
think this needs to be ideal
anyone else wish to speak to Yes uh
representative kuta
I just wanted to say that I noticed in
the top section it was saying that it
kind of protected discounts and stuff
but then in the bottom section it
actually was saying that they couldn't
offer discounts which was really
conflicting and also concerning because
I know a lot of places do tend to offer
veterans discounts and we also didn't
have any veterans that were coming out
and saying that they had ever been
discriminated against that it was a
problem there was nothing I just checked
to see if anything had been submitted
online and there wasn't anything online
either so in the absence of any examples
of it happening and the potential to do
more harm than good with the fact that
it may be taking away discounts that
veterans are currently having I
I agree with italing the bill all right
anyone else have anything they want to
say on uh HB 543
yes representative Stapleton
I'm also a veteran and I think this bill
is a solution looking for a problem and
I would oppose a
uh I'd be with the Ito all right I'm
anybody else have anything they wish to
say on this bill all right are we ready
for a vote on HP 543 the motion before
us is itl and I would ask the clerk to
call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes reptrip
yes rep Grayson yes clerkutab yes rep
Perez yes rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes rep dilorenzo rep Eaton
yes
yes rep page yes
yes Brett Macbeth yes rep Divine yes rep
Lanza yes rep Manos yes repter yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes unanimously 20-0
yes absolutely that's I agree
um and uh representative testerman could
I ask you to write the report
yeah thank you thank you
all right
um
all right next
we've turned to HB 647 relative to
causes of action for individual rights
and the chair recognizes representative
Alexander for a motion thank you Mr
chair I move um HP 647 and experience
legislature second
seconded by representative Wallace
representative Alexander do you wish to
speak to your most yeah I do
um there's
there's a lot of things wrong with this
bill
um I made a little bit a little list
um number one there's no standard
um the one standard we have in here is
on page two line 23-30 it's a use of
four standard
um and when asking some of the witnesses
um I think maybe the committee remembers
when I asked about if a Department of
Transportation employee paints a line
incorrectly will the court use the use
of force standard to prosecute them
under qualifying their qualified
immunity if this bill is if this bill
passes number two
um there's already an Avenue for an
individual to sue a government entity if
they can prove through just cause that
they're that the government entity acted
in a wantner reckless way a great
example um representative Lynn can
probably describe it a little better but
in Manchester there was a case with
police officers acting in a want in a
reckless way and that is currently in
the court system number three this is
not just a violation of a constitutional
right this is a violation of any law any
state law any local law and actually the
only the only groups of people that are
immune from this bill are the
legislature and the judicial branch so
that just goes to show you you know if
you want to pass this bill let's just
make the legislature involved too and
then we'll all get sued for this stuff
um number four
there's no it's the argument is there's
uh no individual liability my problem
with this
um
is if there's even just cause that can
cause a hearing for an individual police
officer
um a firefighter EMT paramedic it causes
a hearing and and that could be cause
for a government entity to suspend um an
employee without pay
um so that lack of pay would be a
financial liability under this bill and
uh number five I'm I mean there there's
no there's not even a negligent standard
so
you don't even have to prove that the
employee acted in a negligent way you
can just say maybe they didn't know but
they still violated the law so they can
sue so there's a lot of things wrong
with this I could probably go all day
but
um I hope that the committee agrees with
me and votes this down thanks all right
other people should be heard
representative Smith
I think I do want to be heard thank you
very much
um
I guess I have a problem
I happen to hold
New Hampshire's
public employees
in the highest regard
I believe that overwhelmingly despite
the fact that we aren't overly generous
in salaries we are pretty generous in
terms of some benefits and certainly in
terms of retirement
we have terrific
um
of public employees
and uh but I also believe
and I think it would be hard for anyone
to refute this that there are a few very
few bad apples
and the few bad apples
do
infect the bushel of all the good in two
ways first they might put pressure on
people to
behave inappropriately but much more
importantly they color how the public
views our public officials they see one
problem one error
and they think oh well that's for public
officials I know that is not true and
you know that is not true I was not
surprised but I was very very saddened
when I saw agency after agency come in
here and
um and say oh no we can't possibly do
this
well if the agency whatever the agency
is
used high standards in terms of
recruitment in terms of hiring in terms
of training all the standards they
should if they provided supervision and
accountability
that would go a long way
to making sure that there would be no
bad apples
if the employer is not willing to
provide that kind of leadership
I think that provides a disservice to
the public and that is why I think it
makes sense to hold the employer
responsible not the employee if the
employee doesn't
follow what's required
and the employer is permitting that
then I think the employer should be held
accountable I happen to take very
seriously people's civil rights as
representative Alexander well knows
there is an amendment that I have
submitted that changes the language to
exclude law and keep only constitutional
violations
I think 1983 has been
um
uh on the books now for 100 what is it
how many how many years 150 years and
the recognition of people's civil rights
is something that I hold very close to
my heart
and have spent my whole professional
life working to protect people's civil
rights
and no one public official or not should
have the right to believe that they can
get a free pass to violate civil rights
the language in this bill which says
very specifically that if a case goes to
court
the court cannot use hindsight they
cannot go back they have to recognize
that in many situations a Public
Employee has to make a very quick
decision based on the information that
they have available to them and we might
look back in hindsight and say you know
maybe they could have avoided that the
court the court can't do that and if a
reasonable person says yes under those
circumstances
ex-public employee acted the way they
did appropriately that's fine I'm
comfortable with that but to to not
recognize Our obligation to protect
everyone's civil rights I think also
creates an environment in which we're
not holding our public employees to the
respect that they deserve the respect
that virtually all of them are careful
and are responsible and act and act the
way they should I know that what I've
just said is
um
it's not that it's falling on deaf ears
I think that people on the committee
respect each other's disparate views
even though they don't agree I have no
illusion that this is going to pass but
when I see people who for example
represent municipalities say no no we
don't want the government to be held
accountable I think that's sad and I
think it's a mis-judgment of what I
would like our public officials to do in
closing I would just say and I think
I've mentioned this before in my town of
Durham
for example
the police chief insists that there be a
psychological test that is not required
but the police chief believes before he
hires because he is going to be
accountable and he wants our police to
be accountable he wants to make sure he
hires the best possible people I have
heard it said well we're having trouble
getting enough people
I understand that I mean restaurants are
having trouble
factories are having trouble and yes
public agencies are having trouble but I
do not believe that that means we should
say okay what the heck let's just hire
somebody who really doesn't meet the
standards that we expect our public
officials to meet that is all that this
bill does it recognizes that we value
civil rights that we respect our public
employees that we believe they are
behaving the way we would want them to
behave and in the few cases when they
don't they should be held accountable
and it is because of that Mr chair that
I will vote against itl and I might be
the only one but I will still vote itl
because the protection of civil rights
is Central to my beliefs thank you
anyone else wish to be heard
I'm so yes representative Perez
I agree 100 with you representative
Smith but my concern is that in this
time right now where our police our fire
our hell are being scrutinized
beyond anything
and
it appears that people are looking at
this just for them
I think
it's not the time to be doing this and I
maybe there's no good time to do it but
right now
there's no way I would ever want to be a
police officer and have to make
decisions on the spur of a moment with
somebody looking over my shoulder and
scrutinizing everything that I do I
agree with you we've just had an
incident where I live where I think
there's some issues that should be
brought forward I just think that
because this appears to be targeted at
our police this is not the time we need
to do everything we can to protect our
law enforcement right now so
yes representative Manos thank you Mr
chair
um I'm I live in Stratham I'm from
stratum and um I met with my tem
moderator yesterday
um and we had a long conversation about
it and we also looped uh Ms burns from
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
into the conversation
um and
um they raised
many of the concerns that representative
Alexander expressed but I also feel
strongly that
um
New Hampshire should have a state
equivalent of section 1983. I think it's
extremely important that we do that and
so my view would be that we retain this
to see whether we can work out over time
over the summer some of the issues here
so that we can see about coming to a
compromise that would both
be a New Hampshire equivalent of 1983
but be acceptable to the public employee
unions and the municipalities the cities
and towns in New Hampshire and so my
thought is that the better course of
action for this bill is to retain it for
study right anyone else wish to be heard
on this yes representative Staples
to use the term qualified immunity but
I'd rather say it's more like a
relevant uh
immunity
to some degree because we have
we have
um
Avenues in law that
take care of those bad apples and you
know even in the recent news we've got
police officers uh on trial and going to
jail
um for wanton and Reckless actions uh we
we have a good solid system of
jurisprudence in law that takes care of
these bad apples I do agree that the
supervision and training has to be
improved
um to locate and remove the bad apples
so they don't contaminate the barrel but
I think we're evolving into that as more
and more pressure goes on to supervisors
that that see they've had people go bad
and go to jail for it I think there's
going to be an evolution on this and for
that reason I I don't want to
to destroy the relative
um immunity that should be there as a
protection on those decisions that are
instantaneous and momentary and
shouldn't be second guessed
yes representative Macbeth thank you so
I certainly respect all the comments of
my colleagues I I don't want to be
anyone that votes um for itl or against
this bill to be painted with a brush
that they're not an advocate for civil
rights because I certainly am and that
is something that I take very seriously
I also there were comments that um I
didn't hear any municipal or Union or
any any any actor say that they didn't
want to be trained and properly
supervised and that there wasn't going
to be accountability for actions but
that's not what this bill does this bill
any mistake any small mistake allows
um a suit to be brought against a town
it can be a voter registrator registrar
or a Department of Public Works engineer
or anyone and I think that that's just
not where we want to be it's that's
that's not talking about Bad actors
that's just talking about humans we hire
humans and humans make mistakes and so I
I I won't I can't support this bill I do
think that that there are issues about
qualified immunity that can be addressed
but
um there are just so many issues here
that are are really just not
appropriately drawn
um so thank you
yes representative cutoff I want to Echo
much of what representative Macbeth just
said and I also wanted to add to it that
I had also heard concerns about town
playgrounds are we going to need to shut
down the playgrounds because it's going
to open us up to a huge liability if
there's an accident on the playground
are they going to sue us for it there
was also concerns from my superintendent
because there's there's a big teacher
shortage right now and they're having
difficulty with with hiring teachers I I
do agree that we act absolutely need to
hold
people responsible for their actions but
I just I don't think that this is the
way to do it right now not in this time
anyone else with any comments yes
representative
um I agree also with um representative
Macbeth and also um representative kutab
to say that we need we need to let's say
make sure that
um
our police as well as all our government
officials are you know have let's let
you say the protection as well you know
they go out every day and serve you know
to do a good job out there and take care
of and protect as well
um and I think what happens is if we
wish to pass this what could happen is
they might decide not to ever there
might be police not wanting to come into
the police force anymore and and some of
the ones that are are here might
actually choose to leave because what
would happen would be it'd be opening up
like um uh the chance of what happened
is they'd could lose their life savings
in regards to just uh any liability That
Came Upon them and people work hard as
we all do to make their savings and to
put their money in the bank account so
we need to think about not only well so
you say anybody like we've said in
whether it be in law enforcement whether
it be Municipal Employees as well well
as Government so I as well cannot
support this bill so thank you anyone
else
representative and then I'll get to you
representative representative
uh I know there was an amendment
circulating I don't know whether that uh
is something anyone's spoken to whether
it changes any of this I I must say it
the way it's currently written even
though I'd really much like to support
um this you know when I see from the
enhancer New Hampshire Municipal
Association you know where it says that
the bill eliminates any governmental
immunities requires the government to
pay for attorney's fees and
circumstances where the government
settles or loses in court and eliminates
any collective bargaining protections
for employees
subject to penalty
um those things I think are troubling
they may sort of speak to what other
people have mentioned I just didn't know
whether there was a circulating
amendment that might heal any of that
representative Smith thank you um as I
think you know representative kurer the
there is an amendment and the amendment
basically removes the um of the language
which talks about law and keeps only the
essential language that talks about
constitutional violation of civil rights
and
um I must say I think I'm we're all
tired and I'm tired and I don't want to
say anything live which I sometimes do
but some of this does sound a little to
me like Chicken Little that the sky is
falling I I there have been lawsuits on
playgrounds always nothing we can do is
going to eliminate irresponsible
irrelevant frivolous lawsuits being
filed they're filed all the time and
they're thrown out of court because
they're frivolous
and and that and nothing we can do can
stop those frivolous lawsuits because
people have a right to have access to
the courts
what this talks about is a violation of
civil rights we're not talking here
about whether we're going to complain
because the baseball field has Turf on
it and people want natural grass that
has nothing to do with a violation of
civil rights we are talking only about a
violation of civil rights and if you
want your town to hire people who do not
want to respect other people's civil
rights that's fine with me I just hope
that my town never chooses to do that so
to say that people aren't going to want
to work because they're going to have to
honor people's civil rights
I don't find that arguing persuadable
and I think I'm probably speaking too
strongly and so I'm now going to stop
thank you
other anyone else wish to be heard so I
guess I I want to just say a couple of
things about this I I appreciate very
much representative Smith's very
thoughtful comments
and I also want to address
representative manos's point about
thinking that there should be a a sort
of a state version of 1983
I think there's a couple of things to
bear in mind first of all
1983 actions although they are usually
brought in federal court can be brought
in state courts state courts have
jurisdiction to hear 1983 actions
more importantly
to the extent this bill and I I by the
way I agree with representative Smith
that I think the Amendments that she
proposes does make the bill better it
doesn't make it in my view it doesn't
make it appropriate to pass it but it
does make it not quite as bad as it was
the
um
the I think the important thing to
understand for those who say we ought to
have
a state
Constitution a right to bring
actions for violation of rights under
the state constitution
I really respectfully submit to you that
it's not necessary because the reason
that you had the reason the whole reason
that 1983 was enacted right after the
Civil War was because of the because
they're under federal law
there isn't there isn't any sort of
common law an assault and battery is not
a violation of federal law a false
imprisonment is not a violation of
federal law
um any of those kinds of things and so
they needed they needed to say they
needed to have a body if they wanted to
enforce the the new Rights created uh by
the by the uh post-civil War amendments
they needed to create a vehicle by which
people could sue for protection of their
Federal rights but
and that's not the case under state law
almost everything that you might say
would be a violation of the State
Constitution I'm not saying absolutely
everything I'm sure you could probably
come up with some clever thing of what
that's not but almost everything that
you could say would be a violation of
the state constitution
is is a violation of the state common
law if the police you know uh use a
excessive force against someone that's
assault and battery if the police
unlawfully arrests someone that's false
imprisonment there's a common law toward
for that if they if they go on your
property when they don't have a an
adequate basis to be to be there that's
trespassed as a common law of trespass
so all of those
things are already in the law and
there's not any reason to to Now sort of
make a new state constitutional cause of
action for those things and and I guess
what I would what I would ask you you
know you might say well what's the
problem if it's already you know a
common law thing what's the big deal
about making it a constitution
here's I submit to you respectfully as
much as I love you know most lawyers
this is like the lawyer's Full
Employment Act because it will be every
every issue
that was you know let's say a common law
assault and battery well now we've made
it a state constitutional violation and
there will be clever lawyers that will
say your honor those cases dealt with
assault and battery we now have a new
constitutional right you should find
that the elements are different or
damages are different or whatever I mean
I could imagine this would go on for
years and years and years while the
courts sort of decide what are all these
new rights and there really is no reason
for it because we have a common law that
provides all kinds of benefits the last
point I would make and I think this is
really important it particularly applies
to police officers or Corrections
Officers but arguably to others
remember this
police officers are the bearer of bad
news
that's almost always what they're doing
when they're having an encounter with
somebody they're the bearer of bad news
so even you know in the most minor thing
you know you're going down there you're
going down this has happened to me
you're going down the highway and you're
going too fast I mean I can remember in
month you know in my I was I went out to
visit my daughter in Montana and I was
driving home and I was driving through
buildings and I was going too fast and
the police pulled me over the officer
was completely professional there was no
but you know I was a little annoyed you
know I mean I I he treated me with
complete respect but you're a little
annoyed she said you know I'm just
wasting my time a little bit and I wish
that I you know I wasn't I wasn't doing
anything dangerous but I was speeding
there's no question that I was
um
just you know imagine that that's your
job all the time to be the bearer of bad
news a lot of people don't react well to
bad news and so police officers are put
in uh in situations where you know where
it's very easy for someone to come and
bring a lawsuit because they're pissed
frankly excuse my language but that's
but that's it even though because they
don't like being told that you know that
they don't like being caught being have
it being brought to their attention that
they've done something wrong and I think
that's
that's unfortunately happens uh all too
often and this would make that even
worse as representative Alexander
pointed out when the police have really
done something wrong it's beyond simply
an error of judgment or something like
that they can and are held responsible
and I think that the current law
is is uh is adequate to do that so for
those reasons with with great respect
for representative Smith I will vote itl
on this bill
foreign
all right I guess we then we're ready
for a vote on uh House Bill 647
um the motion before us is itl and I
would ask the clerk to please call the
roll Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes
clerkutab votes yes rep Perez yes rep
Smith
repore again
up he's not here
rep Delorenzo no
rep Eaton no
rep page
Brett Macbeth yes rep Divine yes
replanza yes rep Manos
yes
rep Terror yes
chairman Lynn yes
the motion passes 16-3-1
thank you
all right all right and so um
representative Alexander I think you're
you're you're not quite busy enough for
this so could we ask you to could you
ask you to write the report
all right and and um will there be a
Minority Report
uh representative Smith
all right thank you
all right
um
okay
but this probably will not be a debate
on the field
that that's another slide that's fine
I'm happy to do it
you can't put it on the consent panel
right now
all right um
let me turn then to uh HB 343 and I see
represent I see uh attorney Rosenberg is
in the back
and we've kept her waiting here all day
for something that I think is I I hope
we're going to be in in larger agreement
on and I apologize for that um uh but um
representative koutab uh I recognize you
for uh a motion
I move ought to pass with Amendment
97 h
mm yeah yeah is there a second I'll
second Mr chair second by representative
Alexander
um all right representative would you uh
like to speak to your motion
so I believe that this bill speaks to
free Brittany
if somebody wants to be released from
their guardianship they need to have
records to be able to show
sorry Alexander he totally gave us that
line
um I will give credit where credit's due
um so if somebody wants to be released
from their guardianship they need to be
able to show that they're at a capacity
to be able to do so in order to do that
oftentimes they need their medical
records and so if we're prohibiting them
from getting them then their Guardian
can kind of keep hold even when it may
not necessarily be appropriate so I
think that it's very important that we
pass this bill and I want to point out
that this bill also does allow for if
the court for whatever reason did deem
that the person
perhaps just really isn't fit to have
their medical records and needs to be
prevented from having them because for
whatever reason it may prevent you know
a possible me
present a possible danger it does allow
for the court to ahead of time with
intent to restrict it thank you
all right anyone else wish to uh be
heard on
the amendment to HP 3 343.
are we ready for uh the question on the
amendment and do we need uh
unless anyone asks for a roll call I
would propose to do it by voice book
all right so we're ready for the
question all those in favor of uh uh
amendment is it 97 yes Amendment 97 to
House Bill 343 please say aye
aye any opposed
all right motion carries unanimously
um now we're on to the main motion which
is ought to pass
um as amended do I have a motion
you want
Oh I thought that was on the amendment
okay all right that's fine as long as
everybody who's agreed we have the
proper motion all right so anybody want
to speak to the main Bill and as now
amended
seeing none um I'd ask the clerk to call
the roll please
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes reptrip
yes
rep Grayson yes
votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
Oregon's not here rep dilorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes
Brett page
Brett Macbeth yes
rep Divine yes
yes rep Manos yes ripter yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes unanimously 19 with one no
vote
I I agree anybody have any problem with
that all right consent
all right last but not least
um House Bill
396. yes
um I just would like to say that I
submitted a last minute amendment to
this bill which was passed to you and I
want to let you know that the only
change in this amendment was that on
page two line four the word when
permitted was eliminated
and on line five when permitted was
eliminated it does not
um it it doesn't change the amended
analysis of this bill but those
um those words were eliminated and that
is
um Amendment 2023-0441h
um zero four four one h
okay
um does everybody have that yeah oh you
gave yep
thank you
maybe maybe it was already oh wait let
me it's my hang on
four four one zero four four one H today
it's got today's date at the top and my
name at the top
oh
okay I don't
I've got my copy but I don't I mean does
everybody does everybody have that
before I'm doing everybody has it all
right all right so um my um and so
that's the only change that is the only
change to it at all there's no other
changes in it
um those two words were taken away twice
okay Mr chair and a uh a motion has not
yet been made only that they're just the
announcement that there is an amendment
so I would move that we adopt uh or
excuse me that we uh Hospital 396
ought to pass with Amendment zero four
four one h
uh all right is there a second
I second the motion all right
um all right so um
uh representative reason do you uh do
you wish to speak to the motion or
represent I'm not sure who's gonna
speak to it there somebody wished to
speak to it
um
this bill just does one thing it
clarifies that the state is not
absolutely forbidden from using
biological sex to differentiate between
groups of people
we should think long and hard about the
implications of our vote today this bill
should be a common sense clarification
of current law
by voting against this bill today we
would be sending the message that the
public entities are completely banned
from having any separation at all for
biological women period
I think the fact that this bill is
controversial should make us should ask
us whether or not we are out of touch
with the majority of our constituents
from both parties
all of us have seen many examples of
written testimony hunt over a hundred
and emails from all ages of individuals
who are concerned about girls being
bullied and their privacy and dignity
is violated by biological males in
locker rooms and bathrooms
around the state look at Milford
those parents and children spoke up how
many haven't out of fear of
repercussions the people deserve to have
their voices heard I have been to
multiple events over the past two weeks
and I have spoken and asked about this
bill at every one of them
people diver deserve to have their
voices heard this bill at least deserves
a debate in the people's house and I
hope you will vote to recommend uh to
pass one grandfather just last evening
said and I quote we cannot provide
equity for a hundred percent of the
people a hundred percent of the time
that is impossible we must provide
safety for the majority and protect
their rights to privity privacy in
sensitive Spaces end quote supporting
this bill does not make me against any
of the
lgbtq community it makes me a person who
is asked and read and feels that I am
working for the majority of the people I
represent and who is willing to Stand My
Ground for them and my information
informed beliefs
I also know that when testifying for
Bill House Bill 104 yesterday was being
done there was a transgender that was
sitting next to someone and
the person next to them said I
understand that you want to use the
girls room
but
how are you going to feel if the entire
football team comes walking into the
girls room when you're there wouldn't
that make you uncomfortable
thank you
anyone else wish to be heard
representative greeson thank you Mr
chair
we spent an awful lot of time during the
hearing on this bill trying to define
words
when words don't have definition
and if they if words are allowed to
change definition too frequently then
the whole function of of society the
whole Foundation of society crumbles
government can't enforce laws because
words don't have any meanings government
can't protect rights when words don't
even have meaning anymore and so these
are this is a very uh
complex issue
but we have a a bill
that
protects
as many people as it could possibly
there's you're always going to find some
exception to anything we ever try to do
but this is actually protecting as many
people as possible
in the in the most
respectful of ways
thank you representative representative
I'm sorry representative Smith
thank you
um when I was young which was a very
long time ago
I was on
Barry with my
family
and we were going from Newport News to
someplace else I'm darned if I can
remember where I must be having a senior
moment
and I saw something
that
having grown up up to that stage in New
York I had never seen before
there was a sign
on the door
of one of the rooms that said
colored people only
and I had no idea
what that meant
and that sign was there
because in that community at that time
which was before
um Brown versus Board which was before
the Civil Rights Act that sign was put
there
because people thought that would
protect the majority of people from
having to do meaning white to having to
do anything with people of color and I
was about 10 at the time
and that was probably
when I decided
that there was something wrong and that
I had to do something about it
I was 10. I hate to tell I'll tell you
how many years ago I was 10 I was 10. 71
years ago except in 10 days it would be
72 years ago
and ever since then as a child and as an
adult
I have tried as hard as I could to
remember that in a true democracy we had
to protect the rights of the minority
because if we only cared about the
majority we only paid attention to the
majority we would not be honoring the
basic documents that brought us together
when my husband and I were married we
were of the same religion
but we chose to be buried by a judge
because we believed that the
constitution
stood in honor of all that we cared
about in terms of how we were to live in
a society
this bill
is designed to deny the rights of
individuals who have made choices that I
can't understand and I'm sure many of
you can understand
it is an alien world to me it is nothing
that I had been part of but I look at my
colleagues here in the legislature who
are in fact transgender and know how
they are entitled to the same
protections that all the rest of us are
entitled to and this bill to me is a
violation of what makes us so
special as a country recognizing that
majority rules
but we have an obligation to the
minority whether they're of A different
race a different religion or if there's
sexual orientation is something that
is
not understandable to us but that
doesn't give us the right to deny their
right to be able to live in a free
society and so I will be
um opposing
otpa I don't think we can do any
amendment that can make this acceptable
thank you
yes representative tur I think you were
next yeah and and I I have many issues
with the bill and I support what
representative Smith
um just said although I I think
stepping back
um a level from sort of the underlying
implications I think this is just a very
dangerous bill for the reason I asked
multiple of our Witnesses on the day
that this was heard
um we're applying a definition we're
applying the definition of biological
sex we are allowing that there are only
two of them and we're basically saying
any public entity can use biological sex
undefined
to make any form of rule or separation I
think the idea of putting down a law
that sweeping that applies to everyone
in the country and even setting aside
the the ideas of of multiple
um
know definitions Beyond two biological
Sexes setting that aside
the idea of passing a law that says any
public entity can use its own definition
of biological sex in in undefined way we
already we heard I believe
representative catabolisted several
different parameters along which
biological sex can be defined and it
just opens a door to basically any
municipality choosing any definition
that doesn't even have to conform with I
believe the four that were mentioned
and saying that's biological sex and
therefore applying a standard I just
think you can't have a law that
establishes a definition and then fails
to define the definition it's just a
wide open invitation to to rampant you
know misuse
yes representative Horrigan you know
sorry I apologize I had to introduce a
bill in another committee
um pretty controversial but not as
comfortable as this one um there isn't
um there's no definite definition of
biological sex I don't think it's a
particularly useful exercise to do it
because there's a lot more than just the
X and Y X and Y chromosomes that go into
it uh some people have well we you know
some people are uh intersex some people
have you know
um you know there's some people of XX
chromosomes who develop into males or
some who have
X y's involved in a female it has a lot
more than do with just a chromosome some
people are like mosaics of like one or
more agile fertilize and then they'll
combine it into one embryo and then a
fetus and there's lots of people
unambiguous genitalia and then lots of
people who are just very androgynous I
think we really uh
I think gender I think your gender
identity and your gender expression is
that's just as biological as anything
else that's involved is probably
more biological than you know those
chromosomes in your DNA we hear so much
about and I think um also bringing for
us but this time there's just a lot of
uproar over it um there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of thing to be a lot of
collateral damage um you know there's
like a situation at a local school which
uh this bill is
somehow gotten tied to I don't think
that's uh I don't think there's anything
this bill can do to help with that
situation especially since that
situation already happened before the
bill
it was interested before the before the
we had the debate on the bill so I think
um you know I think
I think the best thing to do is just
leave this
leave this be and certainly uh trans
people they they're more worried than
you know School Board member Milford and
anyone else they're walking on eggshells
all the time they're afraid of much
worse things than being sued you know
they're afraid of being harassed attacks
sometimes many times even uh even
murdered so I think uh
I think we should uh I think we should
Live and Let Live and I think we should
uh you know not not pass this bill so
all right thanks representative Perez I
understand exactly I lived in um
Virginia in the 50s I have I'm 100
Italian I have half my Italian family is
very Olive skinned half a light like me
I had a cousin when in the 50s that came
to visit us and she was not allowed in
the movie theater
because she was dark-skinned and it was
summertime so I I understand the black
but you can tell if a person is of color
you cannot tell the biological sex of
someone who is transgendered what
concerns me and I understand
them and I understand
their rights but I want to know this is
used this is happening in schools
everywhere most schools now allow boys
and girls to go into any bathroom I know
it's true in Windham I know it's true
and Dover Milford Londonderry most
schools are allowing boys and girls in
any bathroom and it is out of control
because you have young kids who won't go
to the bathroom in school and wait till
they get home
horrible problems with that but what I
want to know is where the rights are of
a little boy using the urinal and not
wanting a girl to be walking in and
where are the rights of the girls being
able to go into the locker room and
change or into the bath bathroom without
having a male walking in whether it be a
transgender male or any male we're
allowing any males to come walking in
any males and my final thing on this is
does this not open the door to
pedophiles if you're allowing a male to
to come into a woman's room in a public
building and
I'm gonna dress up like a girl that day
it opens the door to pedophiles and I
have a real problem with that having
young grandchildren and let me tell you
a story about the past when I was born I
was born Christina Anna Maria Ferrante
c-h-r-i-s-t-i-n-a
that was changed to
k-r-i-s-t-i-n-e legally changed when I
was a couple years old because of
headlines that said Christine back in
the 50s do you know who that was that
was Christine Jorgensen that was the
first sex change operation it was so
upsetting to my old-fashioned Italian
Catholic Family that they literally
changed my name to be spelled
differently we have come a long long way
I have respect for people who choose to
do this
I have respect for them to putting
themselves for it but I also have
respect for the fact that I have a right
as a female to go into a bathroom and I
have a respect to my privacy
I'm sorry representative Alexander and
then representative thank you Mr chair
um so
I voted against a bill similar to this
last term
um I think there were significant
language issues with it
um 396 as it is right here without the
amendment I think there's a lot of
language problems with it I think it was
clear the New Hampshire attorney general
came in and outlined his concerns with
it
um among others I believe the amendment
significantly improves it so I mean it
just says the state has a fundamental
interest
in
biological sex but it keeps it narrow
right it only says in these specific
situations it doesn't Force anybody to
do anything it just says that there's an
interest and that the state May at some
point use that
um in three situations in lavatories
athletic events
in Mental Hospitals and prisons
so
um
I'm voting I like the amendment I'm
voting for it thank you representative
foreign I don't like the biological sex
is not defined in this bill however I
would like to point out that
in Milford they did make the decision to
separate the bathrooms anyway even in
the absence of this bill they made the
decision to do that and then they they
later rescinded it so I do feel that it
can already happen and so even for those
against this bill and I'm not saying
that I agree with it even for those
against I would say
perhaps at least it's limiting the fact
that it can only be used for these three
purposes and we're not saying
right now it's kind of we're not saying
you can't use it for any for anything
and so it's already being allowed to be
used for things and so if it's being
more specific that it can only be used
for those three things I think in some
ways perhaps it actually is offering a
little bit of protection
so I guess um I'm sorry did you want to
say something representative Divine yes
please
after listening all the testimony I
understand that people have their you
know concerns
um personally I feel like this bill is
just way off base even even the um
um respectfully the amendment even
though I understand it
my question would be is how would you
enforce something like this on say the
school elementary school level the um
the Middle School level the high school
level then you're getting into the
college level then you're getting into
whatever beyond that in athletics say
within this state how is something like
that enforest I mean to me there's
there's nothing in here that would
suggest that other than leaving it to
private entities or or public entities
and there would be direct
um
uh
there would be it just to me would be
extreme discrimination that would be
unconstitutional to
anybody that is
biologically
sexually labeled within two categories
male and female or inter sex and and I'm
like how does that work if you have a
bill like this that's going to pass
there's just no mandating I think you
know it should be States it should stay
in the schools you know like the schools
could monitor those bathrooms all on
their own but nobody wants to do it the
parents are the ones that are up and you
know having problems with this
I I I I don't we didn't hear any
testimony from kids but we did get one
testimony that came in from um a
transgender girl
um online through email and and
you know she's doing everything
appropriately
how can you how how can anybody like sit
there and tell like some parent that
their kid is born a certain way oh and
and that's what's Happening Here
but hang on did somebody else anybody
else that hasn't spoken already or wants
to speak
representative Andrews thank you Mr
chair
I am a person that believes and Live and
Let Live everybody should be protected
I agree with the representative Perez
and everything she said and I believe in
this bill
when I go into a bathroom and it's
labeled the women's and that's the one I
choose
I do not want to come out of a stall
and have some man standing there and it
can happen the way things are today
in schools
every child should be protected and is
up to us adults to protect them because
they have no one else
now when you start talking
or speaking
about students that might be modest and
don't want the opposite sex
et cetera et cetera in the same bathroom
with them
they have that right just as much as
anyone else does
someone you know as a sister this whole
situation is something somebody's got to
have a figure out if somebody's
transgender they should have their
rights LGBT they should have their
rights but the child that is modest and
doesn't want the other sex in the same
bathroom with them their rights need to
be protected also thank you all right
anybody else representative tour
yeah just just one more thing
um
the first question I believe this
modifies a piece of law around
um changing
public documents that have sex listed
first well not the amendment the
amendment doesn't but oh original Bill
did you're right but the amendment does
not have anything okay I'll I guess I'll
Reserve that for I mean the amendment
doesn't change in that in that regard
but yes I mean it it
let me just hold that thought and come
back to it representative Horrigan
thank you the talk about schools and
bathrooms have resonates with me because
I was a
well and I'm probably not the only kid
always harassed there's a lot of
harassment and bullying that takes place
in uh bathrooms and locker rooms but in
my case uh that was all entirely by uh
that was all almost entirely by uh boys
my own age or very you know CIS males as
they call them so there's no
no ambiguity about their gender identity
their gender expression they were just
they're just being jerks and all other
jerkiness ends up being kind of sexually
tinged I um
don't know if any of them any of them
were were in fact gay or anything so
that's and then
um another time I
uh when I was probably my early teens
about 14 or 15 somebody did try to
sexually assault me in a men's room it
was a older band once again presenting
as a man as far as you know entirely CIS
male had the XY chromosomes and
everything so this anything happens
you're not preventing this from
happening anyway it's uh and uh
institutions do do the right to uh
anybody who harasses or assaults anybody
in the bathroom is a is uh is in trouble
and I don't think ever barged into a
ladies room but I hear they're not that
much different than Men's Room a little
bit nicer sometimes but um and uh I
never met a transgender person I knew to
be transgender until I was in college
and uh
well he or she was a pretty outrageous
person but I don't really remember she
was not out to uh I don't remember ever
like assaulting anybody you know she was
a pretty
she she was a pretty normal uh she so
you know I don't know what they call her
enormous very exuberant person but she
was like certainly not out to harass
anybody she was just out to have a good
time like the rest of us and get through
life without uh going crazy so that's um
so I just I feel this bills isn't
necessary and I do worry frankly about
this uh
transgender kid in Milford I guess I'll
use that they pronoun form um obviously
if we believe what her friend's mother
said and her mother I'm sure believed
that what she said was true and was
acting out of love um
that you know those one kid acting
allegedly acting like a jerk and even
though we don't know who that kid was or
any details other than what we heard I'm
sure the other people in school know
about us that's and the other people in
their town
I really
not that I condone
what they allegedly did but it's got to
be
it's got to be pretty horrendous with
that child's family and their uh and the
child himself are living through so
that's like I'm sure it's like not not
fair and then one of the things I worry
about with it's a debate and hoping
they're making worse is we're probably
making things a lot worse for that
one
you know that one kid and their friends
um in in Milford so they're being I'm
obviously probably being ostracized
harassed who knows what else as I said
I'm sure pretty I'm sure most people in
town have a good idea which kid this is
so it's not really
so it feels a little bit unfair to be
first of all to be legislating an
anecdote I hate anyway but legislating
the basis of that one anecdote I really
hate and I know there's more to it than
that but I think just the timing of this
is uh
is very bad so I mean I would be against
this bill anyway but especially against
this bill at this time while this you
know controversy is going on the
otherwise very peaceful little community
of Milford you know one of the most
beautiful towns in New Hampshire but
there's something ugly going on there
and I don't want to make it any uglier
and Afraid this bill would make it worse
so because
all right um representative Perez
this is going on in every school
every single school and it is not just
transgender first of all personally I
don't think it should be in the schools
at all you ask how it will be enforced
just like it's always been enforced
Johnny you use the boys room Susie you
use the girls room
most schools in New Hampshire because of
the existing laws have put into place
that boys and girls can use any bathroom
they want okay any bathroom they want be
aware of that it is true
it does isn't so it's an issue in the
elementary schools because Susie doesn't
want to go into the bathroom in the
third grade and have Johnny walk in but
the problems that are happening at the
high school at the high school is is you
have non-transgender boys that are
allowed to go into the girls room and
you know just like boys always did oh go
peek into the girls locker room but it's
more than that I can go into that
bathroom because it is allowed in my
school district
that is what's happening
privacy
you know as an adult you can protect
yourself
as an adult you can protect yourself as
a child they cannot protect themselves
they can't protect themselves from being
put into horribly awkward positions and
that is exactly what's happening and if
we don't want to protect the children
who are we going to you wonder why
parents weren't here parents are not
here because they are afraid of
repercussions I was on a school board
when my now 45 year old daughter was in
the sixth grade I voted against things
okay her teacher in the sixth grade
abused her would not let her go to the
bathroom to the point where she ended up
peeing her pants in the sixth grade my
daughter in her 40s now still reminds me
of that things happen
we cannot we need to protect our
children if you want to have anybody in
the bathroom as an adult here
anywhere that's fine but we need a law
that's going to protect young people
and this law is the only law that's
going to protect him schools are having
problems high schools are having big
problems they're being covered up you
can go to the superintendent parents
have gone and complained kids are afraid
they'll be repercussions from them
all right so
representative Stapleton yeah thank you
Mr chair
my emails are running I don't know 40 to
50 maybe higher to one and supported
this bill
there is a sense of fear and
apprehension out there on the part of
parents and I think that comes from the
fact that the children are upset and
maybe reporting or relating this stuff
to parents
traditional anatomical separation
or decency safety and privacy we've had
for hundreds of years if not for
thousands of years
this is a orderly Society tradition
and I have to ask is our culture
departing from Good Sense
and I would say yes it is and we're
getting off on tangents and extremes and
I think it's time to restore sanity here
and I I'm going to support the the
amendment which fixes some problems and
the bill because I think we need to have
restored order and common good sense
back into our culture and stop the
license to Bad actors and stem the aura
of fear and apprehension
so representative testerman
I agree with you completely
um
we've got a movement in this state
uh
or schools independence of schools and
and the state helping provide the
parents with some some money so they can
go to to private schools to to religious
schools but or or are do homeschooling
and a lot of it has to do with the
parents and the children not being
comfortable with what's going on in the
schools I was on the school board until
recently uh you you could try to find
out why all this was happening and
everything just sort of got hidden
behind a screen
this is not right
you can talk about there's a wonderful
way to to be transgender is a wonderful
way to be this or be that
but there is the right and there is the
wrong and there are some Alternatives
and if you'd like to use those
Alternatives be my guest but this is not
you know doing something like this is
not the way to do it and if we have to
do some correction in the schools so be
it uh and having one or two percent of
the kids unhappy with whether they can
go to a particular bathroom or not in
school that's life's rough yeah if you
pick if you pick some alternative
uh to to your sexuality yeah
you need to learn there is something to
pay for it
so I guess what uh what I would like to
say on this is is this
um first of all I um
I haven't I haven't moved to introduce
my Amendment which is virtually the same
as representative Perez's Amendment
except for the
um the words when permitted uh
I I I know that uh that that the removal
of those words likely came because uh my
friend who's in the audience Mr Hewitt
and the Cornerstone Group thinks that
that's having that language in there is
a bad idea I have to say I'm not sure I
agree with that I don't I mean whether
you put that language in there or not
it's the effect of the language is to
allow circum some three particular
circumstances when
classification on the basis of
biological sex is permitted I I guess
what I would say is this
um
you know I recognize that people have on
both sides have you know have sort of
strong views on this and I respect the
the views of everyone who's spoken here
just as I thought the people who
testified at our hearing on both sides
uh were were good people whose views I
respected and I really felt that I
learned something from from the hearing
what I would want to what I would
emphasize to you in support of this
amendment is is this
first of all recognize this is a very
narrow Amendment one of the reasons that
I first talked about I first sort of
thought about coming up with an
amendment like this was I was concerned
that the language in the original bill
had too much wiggle room it was too too
likely that it could be a it could be
applied to other circumstances so what I
try to do is I basically said look
what are the what are the areas where
people are complaining
that there's something wrong in this
area is it are people saying you know
don't hide we we should be able to
discriminate against transgender people
in employment
in housing in any of the other things
that are the subject of the Civil Rights
Acts no nobody said I haven't heard
anybody say you know we we got to stop
allowing transgender people to to be
able to be hired in this business or
that business or they shouldn't be
allowed to to uh rent an apartment or or
any of the other things that are the
subject of what we would normally think
are are the Civil Rights Acts people
have concerns in three specific areas
where it seems to me there really is a
there really is a basis for the concern
people people are saying
wait a minute I'll you know a locker
room that is a that is used by multiple
persons or a or a uh uh a lavatory
that's used by multiple persons that's
the kind of thing where there really is
a strong privacy interest not to want to
not to want to have somebody who is uh
is of the other biological sex in that
in that facility the same with sports
with particular Sports not all sports
you know I when I as I as I think I've
mentioned to you before my my hobby is
target shooting when I first started I
started when I was 14 years old and for
years and years and years there was a
women's division because there weren't
that many women women Shooters and so
there was a women's division well they
stopped that probably about 10 years ago
uh because there's a lot more women
Shooters now and more importantly they
beat the men regularly because shooting
is not you know it's not something of
physical strength makes a lot of
difference so there's no more there's no
more women's division in shooting
because they don't it it it's just
outmoded
um
and as I said the women's the last two
Olympians in in rifle shooting I from
the United States I believe were women
but anyway I'm I'm getting sidetracked
here I I
try to cover only the three areas where
I thought there really is a valid basis
to say classification based on
biological sex
makes makes sense I would also note this
is in no way a mandate this bill doesn't
say you shall do this it just says you
governmental entities are permitted to
do this if you if you want to
the last point that I would make on this
is I think that I think this is really
important
remember this
separate but equal although it
absolutely we absolutely reject that in
the in the area of racial discrimination
as we should
we don't reject that in the area of
sexual discrimination if that were the
case if separate but equal could not be
allowed you couldn't have eat forget to
put transgenders aside
you couldn't say that we have for for
particular for completely straight
people
so a boy could say I want to go into the
girl's bathroom you're discriminating
against me if you have separate
bathrooms it has to be just one that
everybody gets to go into or a girl
could say the same thing we don't say
that if separate but equal couldn't be
allowed in in circumstance Title IX of
the the federal Title IX with dealing
with with uh uh Federal funding for
sports programs
um that that would be a violation of the
Constitution because in fact in Title IX
it the the you know there is a sort of
separate but equal you have you have a
uh a male you know the the varsity
football team that doesn't mean that
women should that women are allowed to
play on the varsity football team it
means that you have to offer other equal
opportunities for women to participate
in sports so I guess what I would say is
there are some areas that sexual
classifications are different from
racial classifications and there are
some very narrow circumstances in which
I I think and I suspect that most people
would agree that the classifications are
allowed
I would note on the at the
Constitutional level
the boss stock case remember which is
was the five to four decision of the
Supreme Court that dealt with
transgender issues that dealt with it in
the context of employment
the court has not dealt with the with
transgender issues in these specific
contexts and as I understand it there is
a split in the circuit in the circuits
about the Constitutional question about
whether some circuits have said this is
okay and I think there are some circuits
have raised questions in various
contexts I don't know that there's any
that has you know that has dealt with a
statute that that sort of deals with all
these three circumstances
so to me I think that this amendment is
narrow it's not mandatory and I think it
does address areas of legitimate
concerns by people who are not you know
homophobic or transgender phobic or
anything like that they just have
legitimate concerns about privacy rights
in in the case of of Laboratories and
other things
safety concerns in the con in the in the
case of of uh facilities of
incarceration or mental health
institutions that kind of thing and
fairness in the case of of sporting
particular types of sports where
everybody can kind of recognize that
um strength or or endurance uh more
speed or whatever has it gives
biological males uh the advantage and
the last point I'll make and then I'll
shut up is with regards to the issue of
Cl of you know biological sex is not
it's it's too vague I I'm sorry I have
to say respectfully we you know it it
really you you don't you can't if
somebody asks you is you know is
somebody in this room somebody in this
room are you a man or a woman really you
can't ask you can't answer that question
I think that you know this isn't this
really isn't rocket science it's law and
we make we make uh we make decisions
based on our common experience
and I guess I would say that I think
most people understand how to
distinguish between men and women and
the last the very last point I'll say is
this
it it strikes me that most of the people
that we heard here as Witnesses they
weren't coming coming in here and trying
to sort of hide
their gender it seems to me that most of
most of the people that are that regard
themselves as transgender they're not
trying to hide that from anybody they're
they're that's they they you know they
say that's that's the this is what I
regard myself as uh uh you know I I've
trans transitioning to be a male or I'm
transitioning to be a female or whatever
um uh so I don't think that that you
know
the sort of how trying to
nobody is suggesting that the school
authorities or whatever should be able
to you know do a you know drop trial
chat uh check I'm not suggesting that
for for a moment
um anyway that's that's it thank you
I think representative Smith
I'm trying to decide whether we're just
um beating a dead horse here and whether
we should just go on but isn't the last
point you made exactly what at least is
concerning me that the people who came
and testified weren't in any way denying
what they are doing that they are
transitioning
um from one
sex to another
and that is true they're not denying it
what they are saying is does that
therefore mean
that they don't have the rights that are
afforded to everyone else in the country
think about it in a different way think
about what we know has happened over the
years that there were people probably a
majority of people who did not want to
have to go into a restroom with someone
of color because somehow they felt that
that would compromise their own
Integrity think of the people who
um
uh and it and it's still happening who
do not want to be associated with people
of a different religion whether that
religion is Jewish or whether that
religion is Muslim probably not
Christian because we live in a country
that is majority Christian
um but we certainly know
um that people could be
I'm not going to go there
um uh
the fact that some people are offended
I think just shows that in 20
23 we in this country are living with
values that are more reflective of the
Victorian era
then of today other countries don't have
this problem other countries
consider sexuality be a normal part of
who somebody is and however they Define
that and we don't make a big deal out of
it and we shouldn't be making a big deal
of that because if we were to pass this
legislation we are saying that people
who are transitioning or who have
transitioned including people in this
very body really don't have the same
rights as the rest of us because it gets
other people nervous and that is wrong
thank you I'm sorry
so representative Manos
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
enter into a dialogue
I want some of what you said so I'm I'm
looking at the amendment and Roman
numeral paragraph three talks about
prisons houses of Correction and then it
goes on and I just wanted to raise the
point that we heard I believe it was
through the AGA that the Departments of
Corrections
um that the Department of Correction and
the how um
the uh prisons make individual
individualized judgments on how they are
going to separate the population and it
was my understanding from the aja's
testimony I believe that's where it came
from that the state wasn't having a
problem about this and so I'm not
I want to enter into a dialogue about
why we're and we didn't hear from any
other state agency the Department of
Mental Health or any other the juvenile
correction system we didn't hear from
any other state agency about having this
problem and they are making
administrative decisions about how to
house or their populations
so that's one point I wanted to to raise
the other point is in paragraph
um it's Roman numeral two but it's the
the first sentence on
under one and two lines one and two on
page two the legislature finds that
permitting classification of persons
based upon biological sex serves this
compelling State interest and then goes
on to describe the three circumstances
and the fact that the um Amendment
states that this serves compelling State
interests doesn't necessarily make it so
a court would have to decide that and
then again I would raise the point that
you also raised about the split in
circuit decisions and I I also don't
know whether those cases are on on all
fours with
um with this proposed amendment and the
underlying bill but the point here is
that these cases are coming forward
there is a split in circuits I haven't
looked at those opinions so I don't want
to offer a position on that but this
will end up being addressed by the U.S
Supreme Court
um
and I think it's an expedient to
legislate in this area until we know how
how that those issues are going to be
decided by courts but I I just want to
emphasize again that stating that
something is a compelling State interest
doesn't make it so
uh representative tur and then
representative Staples
yeah so I'm going to revisit what I
started to say earlier I'm not sure if
we're talking about the amendment
specifically at this point or whether
we're talking about the broader bill so
you know I'll just say it and hopefully
in the context
um you know what I started to say was
this
um bill
um Alters a section under 260 21 for
identification cards under the
department of motor vehicles
um
first question I asked
representative
um
thank you
was
does this pertain at all to either birth
certificates or driver's licenses and he
said no this is separate from that
what's marked on your driver's license
or your birth certificate is not
um is not what this is trying to do and
that's not what defines biological sex
so
I guess that's my first point is I think
it's kind of odd to put a piece of
legislation in a section and I'll read
the section that is here
under
um 260 21 says the identification card
shall bear the name address date of
birth blood type optional
and then not optional gender indicated
as M for male f for female or X for
other
um birth certificates have that too
um so the simple classifications that I
I will call not biological
um that already exist and are written
into the law that we're trying to add to
basically create definitions that are I
think
when I hear representative Perez and
represent Andrews talk more in line with
what I believe they're talking about
um you know if we have new technology
going going back to representative
Stapleton we have new technology
didn't exist back in the day I guess you
know to change people's
physical characteristics or outward
characteristics to match their beliefs
and their identity
in a way that actually defies exactly
what we're talking about so if you said
biological sex would you I don't know if
you can see that it was established at
Birth but
if it is
by whatever definition then the person
who is transitioning and who was born a
female but now has a beard and you know
very male characteristics or vice versa
if we go to biological sex as opposed to
the kind of sex that's defined on the
documents in the section of the law that
we're trying to modify
then we are basically saying that's the
imposition that the public entity is
allowed to make they're allowed to say
the bathroom is for biological males and
so someone who was born a biological
um
mail but has transitioned and now has
sexual characteristics associated with
females would go into that bathroom
right I mean that's I don't know if I'm
making this clear but I feel like both
the type partial law that we are working
with and the applicability of this if it
actually were to put in be put into
practice both run contrary to I think
the the things that represented sorry to
character mischaracterize if I am but
the the what I heard think I heard
representative Perez and representative
Andrew say which is you know
would you or would you not want to force
there to be a person with a beard in in
the Ladies Room biologically that person
probably is still technically at some
level the sex they were born to but they
don't look that way and so it's not that
easy to tell it's not a slam dunk and I
feel like this would actually undermine
the goals of
providing Comfort both to the person who
feels that they belong in the men's room
because they look like a male and the
other males that are in the men's room
because they think that the people that
they want to be surrounded by would best
be males do you understand why I'm I'm
raising this point both in terms of
where it is in the law and in terms of
in terms of the applicability of the law
setting aside my previous
um objections to not defining what
biological sex is because this is where
it actually hits the road
miss Mr chair
um
we have some very thoughtful
intelligent
write people on this committee who are
very
interested in discussing a very complex
issue
I'm one of them and I probably talked
way too much but I'm not sure at this
point that we are convincing anyone to
change his or her view and look for it
if you would not object I would like to
suggest that we move no I think you I
think you make a very valid point
representative Smith and I think yeah I
think we've we I think we really have
had a full debate on this that would be
so the the motion before us is the
motion
um uh of ought to pass as amended with
uh representative Perez's Amendment
2023-441h and that's the question before
us uh so I guess I'd like to ask uh
representative koutov to to uh
do a roll call on that Amendment
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton YES Prep
trip YES Prep Grayson yes
clerk votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
rep Horrigan no rep dilorenzo no rep
Eden no
prep page no Brett Macbeth no rip Divine
no
rep Lanza no rep Manos no ripped her no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10.
10 10. all right
to make a motion yes
second
all right second advice representative
Eaton is that right yes all right uh
would you like to uh
speak to your motion now
for 10 years or so
so
um all right anyone else
wish to speak to this so I guess
um
I guess what I would say on this I
respect what what representative Smith's
I respect representative Smith's motion
I I I tend to think that this
is a matter we ought to have you don't
have to go to the floor without I
suspect what will happen is if this
motion fails there'll be a motion of itl
um which I expect will also fail and
that will mean the motion the bill will
go to the to the floor without uh
without recommendation I actually think
that that might be a better resolution
let the how let this is a you know this
is an issue that has a lot of different
uh has arguments on both sides which I I
think are the arguments on my side are
better but I respect the arguments on
the other side and uh and so I guess
what I'm saying is I I don't really
think that that anything is going to
change by the Fall that would make us
you know in other words if if somebody
were suggesting look if you just did
this tweaked this or did that we you
know we could come to an agreement but
it doesn't sound like that's the case so
we're going to be in the fall we're
going to be right where we are now I
think I'd rather have the
have it uh have it go to the floor and
you know without recommendation but I'm
I think representative McBeth you were
no thank you because I wasn't able I
haven't spoken on this bill yet sure of
course I um I wanted to say that like it
goes to what my College Tour said and
also Smith I mean I do believe in civil
rights and
um one of the comments that was made was
you know you could tell the I you you
could the people that were testifying
here they were going through transition
but they weren't hiding their sex and
they were you know you could guess it
well I don't believe that I for me I
would never try to guess someone's sex
because the Sexes aren't just male and
female just like a representative tour
pointed out on our birth certificates
and on our driver's license we're
allowed to say other there are several
other Sexes
um and this bill completely negates that
um and and the testimony that you you
know you think that you could guess I
you know I don't guess because you're
wrong lot of times whether however
someone is presenting they're more than
two Sexes and I really ask people if you
aren't aware of that or people are
claiming they're not just always in
transition and in between male and
female there are other other genders so
I just um I need to say that because
being silent is
um I think not putting all the facts out
so can I can I may I just ask a question
representative so I'm not I I appreciate
what you've said but I'm just I mean
does
do you think that what that what you
said is a reason to as to retain as
opposed to having it go to the floor
without absolutely because I think that
this bill defines gender or as two and
we have other state
our driver's license and our um uh
statistics what is it called Essentials
I'm sorry I'm tired you know the vital
statistics where they say no it's not
just two there's an other and the other
is got more facets in it that I can't
educate you I mean I don't not educate
it on myself so yes I do feel that is a
reason to retain this bill I mean um
because we're going against
other
um other state law and other state you
know what other state agencies have
recognized is that sex is not just male
and female
right I mean sorry I I I I don't mean to
argue with all I'm saying is wouldn't
wouldn't what you just said be a reason
to have a vote of itl in your view and
then it would you know it would go to
the floor with with no recommendation
and then the legislature would decide
um now as opposed to in the fall which
which side they agree with I I don't
think so because this is something that
requires a lot of thought I mean we all
have given a lot of thought a thoughtful
consideration not just a knee-jerk fear
of certain things that can be stirred up
easily so no I don't think past sending
it on the floor is is what's the best I
think retaining this bill is best and
looking at you know
how we should push it forward to really
if we want to protect people's civil
rights and people's privacy which are
both very concerned to me then let's
figure out how we can do it
yes uh I'm sorry did somebody else
representative Perez
I understand
saying that you know wait you know law
cases let's see I'm not a lawyer I'm a
nurse
um
retired
this is too important right now because
what is happening right now can't wait
how many times have we heard when we've
had things happen in schools school
shootings that they knew there was a
problem but yet they couldn't do
anything the police couldn't do anything
until the law was broken
I'm not willing to wait we have parents
we have children we have adults that are
having issues they are being bullied and
I'm not saying by transgendered but they
are being put in awkward uncomfortable
situations on a day-to-day basis I don't
know how many of you have young
grandchildren talk to them ask them how
they feel about a boy going into the
girl's room or a girls going into the
bathroom
I've spoken to some people who are
extremely
liberal compared to me
and they feel they do not want their
daughters in a bathroom when any male
not just transgenders any male can walk
in any male it's going to reach a point
where granted we may have taken our
little boys into the ladies room when
they were little it's going to reach a
point where we're going to go in with
them no matter what age they are to
protect them because they are children
we need to protect the children now if
you want to later change it and make it
different for adults but right now
because schools are allowing this we
need to protect the children we are the
only ones that are able to protect the
children they can't protect themselves I
worked in Boston I saw abused children
horribly abused nobody was protecting
them
so I you know what I guess what
representative Smith
yeah here I go again I have three
grandchildren a 16 year old girl and an
18 in a 21 year old boy I should
probably should say man but I'll say boy
I call them the little ones but one of
them six foot five they think we're
completely out of touch with the world
that they live in they pay absolutely no
attention and they one lives in
Washington one lives in Vail Colorado
one's in College in Connecticut they say
they're all perfectly comfortable with
with
this movement that none of us really
understand that makes no difference to
them and they laugh at how we get
concerned and I think that those
reactions are much more in keeping with
what most of of people that age are
their parents might not feel the same
way
but they do they let what happens
happens and it doesn't involve
aggressive sexual behavior we all know
that there's aggressive sexual behavior
that we are responsible for in this
state because we have the sununa center
where people who we whose salaries we
pay have acted offensively and abusively
to the kids who were most in need of
kind care understanding we're part of
that we know that churches have
experienced terrible situations where
the very adults who young people are
told to trust have violated that trust
this happens in the world we can't
pretend that it doesn't happen what's
we're talking about here is not in those
categories I still would like us to vote
on my retention motion representative
Paige you have been you have been you
have been very quiet throughout this
week I haven't said a thing and I
realize the hour so I apologize to my
colleagues I joke with my friends that I
have a minivan at home and I'm not
afraid to use it and I say that because
um when I drive three kids around in a
minivan I hear a lot I try to be as
quiet as I can so I can hear all of
their concerns and what's going on at
school
and I can only say I've never heard this
as a concern and in fact to
representative Smith's Point what I do
here
uh
is actually
um
the acceptance and the non-issue of this
it's not of top of mind so I can only
speak to my experience on that but I do
want to reiterate what representative
Macbeth said in terms and also what
representative Smith said earlier with
respect to committee work it seems like
this body operates well
when the Committees have the opportunity
to digest things and think things
through before they get to a full floor
so vote and wear emotions and and not
everything can be heard as quickly or as
easily as possible as it can be in a
committee so that's why I think
representative Smith's motion to retain
is a wise one representative Stapleton
I will oppose
a retention
um
we we've what are we doing with a
retention we're going to sequester this
bill to our confines
denying timely open debate
in the Full House in in the greater
audience
I don't think by retaining it we're
going to change many minds or develop
solutions to a
multi-complex problem and problems
involved with all of this
so I believe we should run it through
the the motion process and send it to
the house without a recommendation and
let the greater body have a say at it
instead of just sequestering this bill
to ourselves when we're not going to be
able to do much with it
all right anybody else wish to be yes
representative
thank you Mr chair all right I don't
have any young children anymore but I
will protect any child
and my one question is that I keep
asking myself
why have so many people
emailed us to pass this bill if we don't
have a problem thank you
so I
um as everybody had a chance to have
their representative
yes oh please no please go ahead thank
you Mr chair
um I am just really upset to hear about
this bill
and
I'm tired of listening to the anecdotes
um about the quote problem or issue
um
I would prefer to hear real evidence and
not anecdotes to uh frame this
conversation my own personal feeling is
that
um I have
I don't believe in censorship as far as
reading is concerned and when I was
probably at about 17 years old I had
read the um autobiography of um
Christina Jorgensen the trans first 10
transgender woman who was out publicly
and
since that time
um I've kept an open mind
and I believe that
our biological Sexes
um go beyond male and female there are
variations
um and there's no reason not to believe
that I just I'm tired of listening to
the false theories and anecdotes thank
you
all right anyone else all right so I'm
seeing none so the motion before us now
is a motion to retain
um and I would ask the uh clerk to call
the roll please
chairman Wallace No rep Alexander no rep
Andrews no rep testerman
yes
rep Stapleton no
reptrip no
rep Grayson no
clerk votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith
reporgan
yes rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton
rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes rep
Divine yes rep Lanza yes Brett Manos yes
Reptar yes
chairman Lynn no
motion passes 11 to 9.
seven to nine retain passes all right
all right and so since it's being
retained we don't need a report
um I think we're done does anybody have
is there anything else that we should um
discuss
so you know what uh yes representative
Tripp
once again back to the retained bills
now we're not going to do any with
anything with these until uh next summer
until the well it's usually the full
representative Smith It's usually the
fall
actually we uh the speaker probably
would not let us do anything with
retained bills until after the house oh
the committee has done everything that
they have to do on Senate bills and so
it could be about the time that we're
beginning to do Committees of conference
which would be in June
um that we could start and that would
probably be the time that we could form
the myriads uh committees that we have
might want to form
um and can act on them during the summer
and in the early poll
um and um we'd have to act by some date
I guess the beginning of November
usually right okay all right yes
representative Manos I just wanted to
clarify we're not meeting tomorrow we're
not meeting tomorrow no we're done you
know what I wanted can I just raise one
issue just just for your for your
thought if anybody knows now it would be
helpful to me what I'm thinking is
um we're going to have uh we're gonna
have hearings next week on the 15th and
16th on the all of the abortion bills
basically then
um what the following week
I would normally want to have us have an
exec on those bills and the couple that
we didn't we put over from but right now
the speaker is saying that we're going
to have session on Wednesday and maybe
Thursday of that week so that we we
can't schedule that what I was thinking
of doing is scheduling our next
executive session for Friday February
24th but that is the week that is the
day before the week of sort of vacation
if if you all are already I'll be there
then then we're not going to do it then
we won't do it we'll do it we'll have
our well I'll figure out if we could do
it on Monday or Tuesday if the other
committees aren't using the room yeah
that's a possibility
um I'm just wondering if it gives us
enough time after the hearings on that
but I won't it's I won't do without you
have my commitment I will not do it on
Friday and I will not do it the
following week because people will be
away and I don't you know I don't so we
will do it we'll do it early you'll
either do it Monday your Tuesday of that
week or we'll do it the week after the
okay Tuesday oh you can't all right okay
would you say we don't have a hearing
tomorrow
um we do not no we're done we don't have
anything close because I had it entered
in my calendar no no so did I I I I
didn't think we were going to get
through it all but we did so I want to
thank everyone
suggestions
can we hang on one second representative
Smith please before people leave I just
want to make a suggestion
um we um we've exhausted ourselves
tonight with important conversations and
I'm not sure we particularly changed
anybody's mind
um and that's not surprising I would
like to suggest that next week on our
hearings on Wednesday and Thursday which
are very very important to the many
people who are going to come to talk to
us
we might want to consider not
asking questions of those people who
come and want to talk to us and we just
listen to them and hear what they have
to say rather than and resist the
temptation to get involved in what might
be
debates so to speak I see
Representatives
uh nodding and I just obviously that's
not a dictate in any way I just would
suggest that people think about that no
no I sometimes Challenge questions can
be challenging in the way they're put
forth no I I got a problem right
now I hear what both of you are saying
and I think I I obviously I'm not
there's not going to be any rule you
can't ask questions but I think the
point that has been raised by
representative Smith and representative
Stapleton is a good one and I and what I
would say is we you know we will not
have debates that I will not permit but
asking questions if you have questions I
guess that's okay I I think represents
Smith's point and representative Staples
point stapleton's point is very well
taken I would suggest that be judicious
in your questions
Judiciary and yeah considerate and
considerate yes
so anyway thank you all we debated some